state of emergency declared by the
governor as a result of the covet 19
pandemic in accordance with the house
rule 67 and the governor's emergency
order number 12. pursuant to executive
order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today an
executive session may be held on a bill
referred to the committee please note
that there is no physical location for
members of the public to observe and
listen contemporariously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporariously during the meet at
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaries listen and if
necessary participate in the meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary s access
excess information has been made
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with the house
rules and rsa 91a
anyone who has a problem assessing the
meeting should call 271 3600 or email
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by a roll call vote let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
with each member stating their presence
and please also state whether there's
anyone else in the room with you during
this meeting which is required under the
right to know law
okay heath you're on
all right good morning everyone
calling the role uh representative john
hunt
i am here and i'm alone
representative john patuck i am here and
representative keith ammon that's me
representative max abramson oh i'm
president alone i'm sorry
representative bonnie ham
here alone
representative de palma
representative
representative dawn johnson
present and alone in the womb but i do
have two daughters
doing their remote learning today
in the house
representative christy bartlett here
alone in the room
representative richard abell
president
and alone others are in other parts of
the house
okay representative chris herbert
i'm here
excuse me i'm here alone
representative connie van gaalton
here alone
representative tina fargo
i'm here alone in the room
okay thank you representative jane
bellew
here home alone
representative anita burroughs
uh here alone in the room my husband is
in the house
okay and lastly representative chris
aguilera
i'm here soon to be alone
all right mr chair that's 16 president
that's the role
all right great thank you
all right so we'll open up the public
hearing on house bill
and
i guess i would ask the anyone who would
like to testify to go ahead and raise
your hands now so i can see who who's
here
because i don't see
yike
oh man
okay
uh yeah yeah now we're off to a roaring
story here aren't we
um
so john you want to introduce the bill
how would you leave
okay go ahead um
okay let me let me get it out of my book
here first
okay she's been recognized to speak to
the to the legislation
good morning mr chair ladies and
gentlemen at the commerce committee uh
for the record representative john
patusik rockingham six dairy
introducing uh house bill 477
uh for representative roy out of
rockingham 32. this bill establishes
consumer protection provisions for
customers of internet service providers
isps
for service outages and less than
advertised download speeds
[Music]
this is deja vu
if i remember right we had this two
years ago and we might have had it four
years ago
um
so i didn't see anything different about
this than we had two years ago
and if i remember right well i'm not
this is my presentation thank you mr
chair
okay
great
uh
representative terry you
uh yes mr chairman uh i am present and
i'm alone in the room okay great welcome
you can put your hand down now thanks
okay
um
i have
nobody
in support who wants to speak to the
bill so anybody who uh who's listening
in is there anybody who supports the
bill
uh
just raise your hand i don't see that
okay
so what i'll do is uh instead i will um
to uh to
who is neutral the attorney general's
office is new neutral
and
uh so uh chair will recognize attorney
guard
guarant sorry d-rod i'm sorry
and uh to uh who is neutral and would
like to
help us out and try to understand the
issue
good
morning good morning chairman members of
the committee thank you for hearing me
this morning
[Music]
sorry our office is experiencing some um
technical difficulties this morning
ironic giving the nature of this bill
but
yes one second for the intercom to stop
intercom i didn't know you guys had it
down there okay
so
again let's start over good morning
i'm brandon garano
consumer protection and andy press
bureau here at the new hampshire
department of justice uh i come to you
this morning to speak um
as a neutral party on this bill
not to speak to the policy but to point
out some issues and concerns that i see
based on my role as the chief of the
consumer protection bureau
and
dealing regularly with consumers that
are experiencing some of the issues that
this bill is designed to protect
the bill before us intends to better
protect consumers
from internet providers by explicitly
providing
protections and requiring the attorney
to
investigate and prosecute cases of
internet providers
that experience prolonged outages and
internet providers that are
advertising speeds and then delivering
speeds that are below the um speed
that's advertised
i i want to give the committee a little
bit of background on how the consumer
protection bureau is currently
responding to some of these concerns
because they are concerns that um
i would say infrequently but
every once in a while come before the
consumer protection bureau
so we have a consumer complaint process
here in the consumer protection bureau
we have a hotline that is staffed by
volunteers that take complaints from the
public those complaints come in as an
official consumer complaint form that
then is reviewed by a paralegal and then
comes to my desk i personally review
every single complaint that comes into
this bureau
i review the complaint for potential
violations of rsa 358a
and
if i find that if true the consumer's
allegation would amount to new
hampshire's consumer protection act
i send it to the business for uh
response
so i said that you know we do on
occasion uh receive complaints from
consumers that are complaining
that their internet is not as fast as
being advertised by the company
we frequently send those to the business
and the business is always very
responsive to those complaints and
almost 100 of the time
the
issue is not on the business side but is
being caused by something
um that interferes with the the speed of
the signal as it is sent from the
internet provider
either before or after it reaches the
consumer who's experiencing the slower
speed and as has been pointed out to to
our office on numerous occasions there
are an almost unlimited number of
factors that could cause an internet
speed at the point that it reaches the
consumer to be lower than the speed was
when it was initially
provided by the internet company those
factors include
the type of equipment that the consumer
is using
the the physical location of the
residence where the consumer is the
environmental factors that surround the
consumer um the strength of the signal
that is being received in a more remote
road location sometimes it's just not as
strong as it is in a more populated um
community
and various other factors including
things like the weather
sometimes can impact
internet speed as well as the number of
devices that are being used in a
consumer's home um if if a consumer has
you know a single modem for their
internet and they're only
on one device to stream movies um that
results in a very different internet
speed than if you know four tvs are
going at once as well as five cell
phones and you know teenagers who are
you know streaming online video games or
online music all day long those sorts of
things
can slow down the internet speed at the
point that it is received by the
consumer
in our efforts to make sure that the
slower speed is not the fault
of the business and is actually you know
something that's being caused by the
consumer
the companies have been very responsive
and very willing to you know work with
the consumers in order to make sure that
they are receiving the speed at optimal
levels
but the way that this bill expands
this office's
requirement to both investigate and
prosecute
any case where an internet provider
speed is below the advertised speed
really creates two
significant issues for this office as
they see it um the the first one of
those is an issue of of resources
um the consumer protection bureau
has very limited resources and we make
the best of the resources we have
meaning that we
you know take the limited resources that
we have and we stretch them as far as we
possibly can to try to investigate
everything that we can on behalf of new
hampshire consumers
those
resources
uh i'm very comfortable saying are
currently either near or at maximum
capacity and simply are not designed to
be
expanded upon to begin a completely new
type and complex investigation which
would be required here
um so i just want to give the the
committee a realistic depiction of if
this bill were enacted and the
expectation is for the consumer
protection bureau every time there's a
complaint of a slower internet speed to
do a thorough investigation in order to
determine whether that slower speed is
the result of something on the
consumer's end or something on the
business's end
we do not currently have the resources
to do that type of thorough
investigation in every case so it would
require additional both attorney
paralegal and investigative resources in
the consumer protection bureau in order
to take that on
i want to be very candid though you know
if if the legislature were to give us
those resources to make this a priority
and say that you know we want the
consumer protection bureau to be
focusing on you know doing a thorough
investigation every time there is either
an internet outage or there is an
internet speed that appears to be less
than what is advertised
that is a very complex and um difficult
investigation to do for a number of
reasons and the reason is that none of
us here
are experts in the area of
internet speeds and internet technology
and how it all works um to the best of
my knowledge and through my interactions
with the various cable companies and
internet providers and just my knowledge
of internet um
something comes from the signal comes
from the internet provider and is sent
out and it's long based on current
consumer protection laws as long as at
the point it is leaving
you know the internet providers you know
signal
initiating mechanism
at that point as long as it's at the
advertised speed um they would not be
violating current consumer protection
laws or this consumer protection law
we would need to prove at what point the
signal lost its strength
and doing that would be an incredibly
complex and potentially invasive process
that would require us to
prove that it was not something that was
the fault of the consumer this could
require us to
have to go into consumers homes to to
take their modems to test their modems
to see if the modem is causing the
interruption we would have to you know
do surveys of individuals homes to
determine how many devices they're using
are their devices at maximum caliber in
order to comport with
the services that the internet service
provider is providing
this is not an easy thing to do in fact
you know nobody in this building
currently has the knowledge base to do
that it would likely require us to
consult with experts
in the area of internet service
providers in order for us to just get an
understanding of how to begin to prove
that um this is something that is the
service provider's fault and not
something that is caused either by a
middleman or by conditions that are
caused by the consumers themselves
this is not an easy thing to do
we have received really good results in
our working with internet service
providers when consumers feel that their
internet is being provided at a speed
that is less than advertised um and i'd
like to point out that under consumer
protection laws
currently any unfair or deceptive act or
practice
is a violation of new hampshire's
consumer protection laws so if you have
my understanding
what this bill is designed to protect
against
is an internet service provider that
advertises you know it's 5g or really
fast internet speeds and that is
actually providing intentionally a speed
that is less than that um currently that
is a violation of 358a that would be an
unfair deceptive act or practice under
current new hampshire law and if that
were happening if we received you know a
tremendous number of complaints and also
that a certain internet provider
was actually providing internet at a
speed less than what they're advertised
we have the tools
already to you know
to bring that internet
provider into accountability for those
actions under the consumer protection
act it would be an unfair and deceptive
action practice
but
by specifically taking
and
making it into a specific carve out
under 358a it's creating an expectation
that the consumer protection act is
going to do a thorough and complete
investigation
of each complaint that comes in on this
matter
and i for the reasons previously stated
i i think that given the current makeup
of the consumer protection bureau and
the resources that it would take for us
to do that at the level that is
consistent with the work that we strive
to do here at the department of justice
it would be creating unf unreasonable
not an unrealistic expectation that we
would simply be able to investigate and
prosecute these cases like we do with
other unfair and deceptive acts or
practices
so i thank you all very much for your
time and your consideration of my
testimony this morning i'm happy to
answer any questions that anyone might
have we do have a question
representative weston has a question yes
uh thank you very much for your
testimony this was very interesting i'm
wondering if you could men talk a little
bit about the outage problem because i
think we've all experienced periods when
we've not had access to the
to the internet at all and is there
anything that can be done when that's
prolonged
so excellent question
the answer is unfortunately you know as
a lawyer we always end up giving this
answer and it's never satisfactory but
the answer always is when you're talking
about the law it depends
um
in certain circumstances under current
consumer protection laws there would be
something that could be done about that
i'll give you two hypotheticals where
something could be done and worse if you
couldn't um if you had a internet
service provider that
has something on there
that malfunctions
or they experience a blown fuse or
something on their end
that causes an outrage
that's within their control
either they can fix it or they can
reimburse consumers for the time they're
not getting the internet
but they continue to charge people
anyways
we would absolutely take those
complaints as an unfair deceptive act of
practice and we would investigate it
however similar to the um to the
internet speed issue um as you know
there are a lot of external factors that
can cause power outages and internet
outages that are outside the control
of the companies themselves you know if
if there is a
if there were you know a serious storm
or an ice storm that you know knocked
out all the power in you know a certain
area of the state for you know a week
and you know it was 100
outside the control of the company
that would be much tougher certainly i
think that they there's an argument to
be made that it would be an unfair
deceptive act or practice for them to
continue to charge even though they
weren't providing any service because at
that point it's their decision to
continue to charge the customer that
would be potentially the unfair
deceptive act
versus you know something that happened
originally on their end that would
create you know some sort of culpability
but it all depends on the circumstances
you know the the overall point that i'm
trying to make is that either way
whether you're talking about internet
speeds or you're talking about an outage
in service for a prolonged period of
time
if the company is charging consumers in
a way that amounts to an unfair or
deceptive act of practice
that is already something that is
covered by our current consumer
protection act that we would have the
ability to investigate
thank you
thank you mr chair um
mr garrett you you started your
presentation off with saying the ag's
office uses volunteers to
um
collect consumer complaints
that surprises me would you be able to
um
tell us how they're trained and how
these where do you get these volunteers
to work in the aeg's office
sure i'd be happy to thank you
so
we have volunteers that man are hotline
um by necessity because you know like i
said we we have a we want to provide to
the the citizens of the state of new
hampshire an opportunity where you know
five days a week they have the ability
to call into this office if they you
know believe that they have a legitimate
consumer complaint that we should know
about
due to our limited staff resources we do
not have full-time or part-time attorney
general's staff that is able to serve
the role of being on the phone
um for five hours for seven and a half
hours a day in order to provide that
kind of service to the community so we
developed a system where we seek
volunteers from the community
that have to apply uh be vetted by this
office have to pass a background check
go through an interview process many of
them are retired folks that have an
interest in giving back to the community
um have an interest in helping people
and have an interest in supporting the
work of the office so they um they apply
they come in usually once one time a
week they man the phones for either a
day or a half day
we train them
we provide constant support to them
throughout the day
both the paralegals in the consumer
protection bureau as well as the
attorneys in the consumer protection
bureau so the volunteers are never on
their own any questions that they have
we support them and try to help them get
the best information to the consumer but
the volunteers role is really to assess
out whether somebody is calling about
something that
is potentially a consumer protection act
violation that we should encourage them
to file a formal complaint for us to
investigate or whether they're calling
about something that is more appropriate
potentially for them to seek either a
private lawyer or to pursue it in small
claims court or something that would be
handled by another state agent for
example we frequently get
people that want to report uh parties
that are regulated by the banking
commission so the volunteers will assist
the person in making a complaint to the
banking commission
but our volunteers are you know
unfortunately covet has really impacted
you know our volunteer situation we have
the fewest we've had in years um but we
are
pushing through and you know doing our
best with the resources we have to
continue to provide excellent consumer
protection to the citizens of the state
our volunteers do a tremendous service
to this bureau we sincerely hope that at
the point that
life goes back to normal like we all
hope it will that all of them returned
and that we're able to have a full
lineup of volunteers again
representative you good morning and
thank you for your testimony uh you just
alluded to the covet situation i'm
wondering if you have found that the
volume and frequency of complaints
coming into your office has increased
now that we have youngsters working from
home business is actually being run out
of uh out of homes i'm working in a
study in my own home
our complaints have been consistently
going up through covid um and you know
it's tough to say what's causing it you
know
the the great thing about having a
hotline
is that it's a access point into the
attorney general's office for anybody
regardless of you know whether it's a
consumer protection issue or you know
they feel that somebody's not complying
with covert guidelines or you know
really anything that they want to call
in about we provide that access point
into the department of justice so we end
up fielding calls about pretty much
everything
that impacts all the state agencies and
all the areas of this office
we do receive a high number of covert
related complaints that we
for obvious reasons we're not receiving
before the pandemic
they're not always directly on point as
violations of the consumer protection
act but we we do see
um
throughout the pandemic we have seen
complaints about various coven related
um scams and potential consumer
protection act violations that we were
not seeing before the pandemic so it has
caused our complaints our complaints to
steadily recruit
increase and i would say our calls and
inquiries
have substantially increased during the
math
thank you
uh representative terry
thank you mr uh chairman thank you
mister is it garagey rod i see a hyphen
after that
uh the hyphen is just to my title uh my
life pronounced garage the easiest way
to think about it is like a garage thank
you sir uh
i'm wondering what uh would you be able
to tell us what uh percentage
of the complaints that you receive are
actually found
to have a
a basis
other than um
[Music]
some of the issues that you've discussed
which are not
actually the fault of the isp
are you asking specifically about
complaints against internet service
i definitely can't give you a percentage
off the top of my head
i can say that
um a lot of the time
it is especially if you're talking about
internet speeds
it is something on the consumer end i
would say almost 100 of the time it is
we don't receive these complaints very
often so the
the great thing about having the
complaint process and the volunteer
process is that it's a great source of
information gathering so if you had a
company that was providing widespread
internet at below advertised rates
we would expect to see a significant
number of complaints coming into this
office because it would be a widespread
impact on the community
what we typically see is one or two
complaints come in
[Music]
one or two a month one or two every two
months
something something along those lines
you know obviously it deviates depending
on the month but that's what we tend to
see um somebody that you know
internet has been advertised as you know
high speed and you know sometimes it's
advertised as a certain speed and the
consumer feels that based on the
performance of their you know their
phones or their devices at home but the
internet is not living up to the speed
as advertised and we're every single
time able to get a response from the
business who is usually willing to work
with the consumer in order to
help them get their equipment up to
speed or to recommend optimal placement
of a device
inside of a residence or sometimes it's
simply a matter of just using too many
devices at once
for the question you may inquire follow
mr chairman if i may with one question
another question
uh
in the instances where you do have
consumer complaints about
uh alleged uh poor internet speed
uh would you be able to tell us um
what percentage uh just just roughly
approximate the percentage of the the
complainants
uh did not first contact the internet
service provider for a resolution but
came directly to you
uh that's a good question i do not
believe that i have the ability to give
a meaningful answer to that we assume
that you ask
so we have a
we require all of our complaints to be
submitted on a
written consumer complaint form that we
have
drawn up where we you know very
strategically ask certain information
from the consumers one of the questions
is have you contacted the business to
resolve this um so
i i can't you know i've been in this
position for almost two years now i've
reduced thousands of complaints i i
can't give you a percentage i got what i
can say is some of them contact the
business first some of them reach out
directly to us
so can you characterize it
further question small percentage thank
you sir
small
i i honestly can't i can't speak to it
without having had an opportunity to
review all of the complaints i'm just
not sure there's a lot of information on
every form i'm not always focused on
that i'm usually more focused on the
allegation that's being made because
regardless of whether a consumer reaches
out to the business first or reaches out
directly to us we always try to help and
try to facilitate a resolution so that
that particular piece of information is
not one of the most important things
that i review when looking at the
complaint form so i would have to look
okay
um yeah so
i'll just try a couple for myself just
just to humor me uh so one time it was
an ice storm
[Music]
and i can see the wire
hanging down
and it's right next to the pole and i'm
the only one on this pole otherwise they
run them on the wire all the way down to
my my house and the wire is hanging down
uh uh and so clearly they own the wire
they're responsible it would should i
have asked them for a refund for that
time that it took them two days to get
again you know
it's it's a difficult question if
if you had asked them for a refund i'd
be very interested in what their
response was
um and you know whether you know
it also comes down to the issue of you
know your poll was down you got to
imagine there were probably countless
other consumers
in this case it was just me but i'm sure
somebody else might have had problems
but but i could see that this problem
was was clearly
just me because the line came all i mean
i'm i'm a half a mile from uh the road
from the street well let me answer it
this way
if if there was a storm and
your
your pole was impacted um your pulp is
maintained by an internet service
provider was impacted in a way that
compromised your ability to get internet
service you notify the company about it
they're aware of it and they choose to
continue charging you instead of making
it a priority fix
credit for the last two days i mean
that's that's a complaint that i would
certainly entertain um as an unfair
deceptive act of practice but you know
it comes down to
do they have the ability to fix it
quickly and if they're choosing not to
uh and continuing to charge you that's a
problem i i i'd say it's probably not
deceptive but it's certainly an unfair
action it was an ongoing type problem
right right in this case they fixed in a
couple of days and i'll say okay i want
two out of 30. i don't know what is it
you know that 15
uh discount or something for for the
lost days um but in another case
um they actually did send an email to
everybody and say that they did have a
problem with their internet where
they're sourcing okay because this is
i'm on one of these
rural rural programs
and they had their sourcing problem and
they switched over to a different
provider which they said they admitted
was slower
but that it was due to the fact that
they had a technical problem
um being able to hook up for that and
they never they give her credit but i
would have to say i never applied for it
because i feel sorry for them because
they're sort of you know running on true
strings and and they're not a big
corporation
but i would use this opportunity to let
everybody know a little bit about
wireless internet in their homes someone
who used to be in the computer retail
business so i uh you know if you my
email is prodigy which is the oldest
email address out there um
is that
when you get your internet from provider
um whether whoever it is and they bring
you a router and some of these routers
have built-in wi-fi
that's the problem that built-in wi-fi
run wears out all wi-fi's get tired
and so you really do have to uh i mean i
think it's unfortunate the companies
don't let people know that but you do
really need to upgrade your wi-fi at
least every five years nothing else the
technology is faster and better
like we have this mesh now so you don't
even need wires but um but your wi-fi
actually does wear out so that's what
would you believe
okay uh thank you very much and thank
you for uh stopping in for us and
helping us out on this one my pleasure
thank you for the time
okay uh so teresa
rosenberg attorney rosenberg
i know that you have
uh
one plus two clients so i don't know if
you want to do both clients at the same
time
oh there she is all right
good morning attorney rosenberg
oh there he goes did you get me now yeah
it came in and out
all right you want me to hang up and
call you back on my cell phone no that
you're right at the moment you're good
yeah i think you i think i yeah i would
i'd come back in let me i'm going to
uh do
lisa mccabe and then yeah why don't you
come back in you know try something
okay all right
so
morning thank you
my name is lisa mccabe and i'm here on
behalf of ctia the trade association for
the wireless communications
industry in opposition to house bill 477
the wireless industry is competitive and
providers compete for consumers daily
wireless providers work with consumers
impacted by outages including providing
credits and other policies
to help customers remain loyal
this legislation would interfere with
that relationship by mandating a
one-size-fits-all approach to outages
many times outages are caused by the
loss of commercial power or backhaul
transport including fiber cuts that are
beyond the control of wireless providers
regarding the outages referred to in the
bill it's important to note that in a
wireless environment there may be many
reasons why our consumer may not be able
to receive service including an issue
with a handset or device which has
nothing to do with the provision of the
service or that a consumer may be out of
a carrier's service area
providers monitor their networks for
outages and restore service as soon as
possible
it's also not possible for them to know
exactly which consumers are on the
network at the time of an outage the
very essence of wireless service is
mobility
many additional provisions in the
legislation do not appear to be intended
for wireless isps as wireless providers
don't offer service directly to a
residence
and do not advertise download speeds as
contemplated in the bill and therefore
wouldn't be able to operationalize these
provisions in the wireless environment
wireless providers in new hampshire
including att t-mobile u.s cellular and
verizon
are signatories to ctia's consumer code
for wireless service in which they've
committed to adhere to
industry principles including providing
ready access to customer service and
promptly responding to customer
inquiries and complaints including
complaints from
government agencies like the attorney
general's office
finally passage of hp 477 would run
contrary to federal law the
communications act provides that no
state or local government shall have any
authority to regulate the rates charged
by any commercial mobile service
mandating a price at which a carrier may
charge a customer in this case a price
of zero in certain instances is part of
the rate structure for wireless service
contracts and these would
bring new hampshire into conflict with
federal law
the competitive wireless marketplace
offers consumers choice and provides the
appropriate credits to consumers when
there are network outages for these
reasons we respectfully urge the
committee not to move forward with this
bill
thank you
okay any questions from the committee
members
all right thank you very much all right
attorney rosenberg you're back
and hopefully
can you hear me now we can hear you
great i'll tell you i'm having trouble
problems with teens with internet with
what you name it teresa rosenberger from
bernstein shurer i'm here today
representing the new hampshire telephone
association and opposition and i'm also
speaking for ellen scarpone of
consolidated in opposition who
unfortunately her husband ended up in
the hospital this morning so i'm going
to speak for her as well
we all oppose the new hampshire
telephone association is made up of all
the landline telephone companies in the
state
needless to say the the
main reason for the opposition is this
is an unregulated competitive industry
and let me say is one who ran fairpoint
communications there's absolutely no
question you want those outages fixed
and back up and running as quickly as
you can because of the competition you
certainly don't want to lose even one
customer over an outage so it's
definitely to your advantage to get
those outages fixed as quickly as
possible it's also to europe
to
give credits when when you can and
various companies give different credits
some people some companies give a
complete credit some people give credits
after 24 hours but the bottom line is
it's to all right then it's not to have
outages and we when we do fix them
quickly as to the second part of the
bill having to do with the monitoring
monitoring of the download speeds i
concur with absolutely everything
uh the attorney general's office said
attorney gerard he's absolutely right
uh it all
you can have the speed to the door but
you have no control over what happens
behind the door so therefore your speed
to the door may be one thing and your
speed on the other side of the door
depending on how many devices what brand
they are is something else so i did tell
everything he said and be happy to
answer questions and
we
all want to keep our our customers happy
that's all i can say thank you
great thank you we do have a couple
questions uh representative
uh
bartlett
thanks very much
nice to see you attorney rosenberger
to meet you too it'd be great to see you
downtown one day that's right it would
be um
just to disclose every to everybody um
theresa and i are both members of the
women's club of concord
um
we have heard this bill uh a number of
times as you heard
um and one of the things that has come
um
i'm gonna repeat part of what you said
was that
the carriers that you deal with and we
heard from other carriers that they are
very happy to give
credits when people have been down
but um
would you confirm that that the customer
has to ask for that credit they because
there are so many
um everybody's got internet
for the most part and there's really is
there no way
for the carriers to be able to tell
individual houses that might be down for
you know two hours three hours a day
but if the customer asks
for this
refund um is it your understanding that
they
will give a credit um
pretty readily
yes it's my understanding if the
customer asks yes they will pretty
readily give the credit and also
represent bartlett it depends on the
company some of the smaller companies
are well aware when they've got an
outage and that it may be affecting
their entire service area or portion of
it so for them in many cases the
customer doesn't have to ask um so it it
depends it totally this thing is so
fluid and flexible it totally depends on
the outage uh but yes if a customer asks
it's my understanding that the companies
will give a credit
thanks very much you're welcome thank
you
representative abramson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh why not simply
create uh a cause of action for the
consumer or for businesses that are
facing an outage
and then uh if they're able to gather
the evidence on their end then then they
could take it to small claims court
if they had to
gosh and i think that's more of a
question for the attorney general's
office i'm not so sure i understand the
question because in most cases with the
outage the are you talking about the
credit because in most cases if you ask
right so
uh actually
technically what he did say
was that it could uh you know if you're
falsely advertising speeds um it is a
violation of the consumer protection act
and uh representative abramson i know
you're new to the committee uh yes you
have the right of trip uh suing them and
you can get triple damages under the
consumer protection act
right fair enough
i do know
abramson i had the issue myself this
summer when my daughter was here and we
had one speed advertised and we
certainly weren't getting the speeds and
so when they came to the house there was
absolutely no question the speed was
coming to the house but once it got
inside we were running i hate to tell
you four computers three cell phones we
wish my daughter was streaming the whole
time so the minute she left and went
back to cambridge needless to say our
speeds went back up
right but it's time for you to get a new
wi-fi inside your house
you are right you need to upgrade your
wi-fi every five years people don't
realize that they wear out they do
i'm gonna go tell my husband that right
now and i should have known that
representative hunt and i and i have
multiple they have eros eros at
one house and orbee
and another one and the mesh is great
you can have units all through the house
and you don't have to worry about wires
it's wonderful
okay
all right now is there anyone else
who
so his is chris hodgson hunched in
around
chris there you are okay see how you
have to do asks
okay oh you jumped on me where did you
go oh there you are okay uh there you go
see i learned my lesson from yesterday
okay
um
mr hodgin you're uh invited to testify
morning chairman hunt may i continue
yes please
excellent thank you so i i submitted
somewhat lengthy written testimony and i
know you have a hearing coming up at 9
45 so i'll be very brief and just try to
fill in the holes a little bit
my name is chris hodgston i am
comcast vice president of government
affairs here in new hampshire and i also
serve as the company's liaison to the
state's emergency management system so
i'm intimately engaged in
any uh outage related issue whether it's
storm damage
uh damage caused by
impacts to our network or the occasional
equipment failure
i just want to confirm for the committee
that in our case and in the case of all
cable providers in new hampshire that
our policy continues to be as it was
when this bill was heard in past years
to provide credits when customers
contact us and express a concern about
an outage or service quality or whatever
it may be
we we believe
that that policy is the right policy it
serves customers well
and the the type of regulatory regime
described in this bill
is is not necessary
um
the bill as other
folks have noted the bill
addresses this concept of speeds and and
advertised fees in a way that's
different from past pieces of
legislation
so i thought i might just
build a bid on attorney gerard's
comments by
highlighting really one of the most
common factors that we see
when customers express the concern about
the down low speeds that they have and
that is
these devices i in preparation for this
hearing i
did a speed test over my wi-fi
connection at home over this ipad 4
which is
only
perhaps five or six years old there are
millions and millions of these out there
in the marketplace and consumers use
them every day
and due to the hardware limitations of
the device the maximum speed i could
achieve was around 8 megabits down by
around 8 megabits up and
at the same
well moments later i did the same speed
test over the same wi-fi
uh device that i'm using to speak with
you today which is virtually brand new
apple ipad and i got the 380 megabits
down by about 19 megabits up which is in
line with the level of service that that
i received from my isp which is my
employer
and uh
and i think that just highlights really
the challenges that attorney gerard
mentioned um i'll just
close by offering to answer questions
about outages answer questions about
speeds i i would ask the members of the
committee to take a peek at my
much more lengthy testimony i
in particular i highlight
independent data collected by the fcc on
a range of isps
and what they found when they
examine download and upload speeds over
the course of now nearly a decade and
that data really does consistently show
that isps are providing at the gateway
which in our case is the modems in our
customers homes the speeds that that
we're advertising
and uh it is not the most
engaging reading but if you're
interested in the technical challenges
that isps experience and what in a real
world environment the fcc has found it's
it's very um interesting and useful so
with that i'll i'll just conclude we
would ask the committee not recommend
this for passage
we do oppose it and be happy to answer
okay
i see no questions for the committee
members so i think i think everybody
has got their arms around this one all
right thank you sir
okay
uh seeing no more questions and no more
attendees with their hands up and
everyone want to speak we will close the
public hearing
on house bill 477 and we had 16 in
support
11 opposed and one neutral
so with that i will close the public
hearing and we're right on time to our
sort on time open up our next one
uh house bill 553 prohibiting renewal of
certain consumer contracts without
express written notice to the consumers
so i'll ask everyone who wants to speak
please raise your hand
and the sponsor
mr baruti
do i see ben
this is terrible
we're having a bad day here
um
oh you gotta be kidding me
i'm i'm glad to introduce it okay yes
great
okay
um
sure
the i'm i'm obviously stepping in last
second
house bill 553
um
it would this bill would make it a
violation of the consumer protection act
for a contract for services to include
an automatic renewal provision that does
not require written acceptance of the
additional term of service by the
consumer
um
interesting bill i
um happened to get a confirmation um
this weekend i
um signed up for a
national geographic for kids
subscription
uh for my grandson
and
in the confirmation
it says and you have been signed up
automatically unless you tell us
otherwise
for this
subscription subscription indefinitely
so i'm thinking that this may apply to
something like that and i'm not sure how
it would be enforced
um but there we go i'm sure we'll hear
okay
uh representative abel has a question or
um
representative bartlett are you aware
that this committee in 2015
passed a bill that the house passed
that
applied this to health clubs in new
hampshire
so there is a pressure
so it only applies
the bill that's in the law that's in
place now only applies to health clubs
is that correct
that bill it only applied to health
clubs that's correct oh well it's
someone who was around in the health
club issue under 23 say 2015 that seemed
a little later because originally the
the issue over health clubs was
um they were selling lifetime
memberships a thousand dollar lifetime
membership and they were going out of
business in a year
and
um so we actually we had a bill in the
committee uh that and this is way back
this is i mean this is this is way way
way back oh you're not that old mr chair
um i'm trying to remember the name of
the attorney general but he's long uh of
the uh who was a consumer uh walter uh
maroony uh he's
anyway the issue uh that we had changed
it was
that um there was
that they can only take a month to month
and they hit your credit card every
month
and that they could not uh do that so
the question i guess it sounds like
there was a the bill came back in
uh was that okay do do when it when that
period of time sometime or something
that they would have to notify you
to uh renew so i assume that's what
you're talking about rich is that they
that if they're going to if you know
some period of time that they have to
renew
so i don't quite remember that
legislation but that could be true but
i would say that
when i one of my my credit cards that i
used to pay all my recurring
bills with uh when the card expired
they all started sending me notices and
say hey your card you have on file is
going to expire do you do you have the
new expiration date so they they are
some of them are very proactive in doing
that but um
in general it is a problem that a lot of
these you know entities say they say you
can join for free
right but you got to give them a credit
card number and if you don't call up and
cancel it they will start hitting your
card and they'll just keep hitting your
card forever you know forever and ever
until until the expiration date and then
they'll rescue you
that works for easy pass too
an easy pass there you go
okay i wonder if that would apply to
this
yeah i i
the way the bill is written it it's any
any any anybody who uh
has what what we call a recurring
revenue contract uh which is a very
lucrative way to do business is
recurring revenue
and um and and but yeah they're they're
sticking right into 358a they're right
right into the consumer protection
statute so
okay uh
i have one person and kyle
baker
promoter
and promote him up here who is in
opposition to the bill
and uh good morning mr baker
good morning mr chair members of the
committee can you hear me okay yes we
can
thank you i will be very brief my name
is kyle baker and i'm here today on
behalf of the internet coalition in
opposition to house bill 553
um you should all be in receipt of a
letter of opposition from the internet
coalition and other industry groups so
i'll just quickly
touch a couple of the main points
of our opposition um concerns um this
bill would create an unnecessarily
burdensome process for consumers and
businesses offering auto renewal
services
consumers in new hampshire would
essentially be unable to participate in
auto renewal programs and would be
required to keep opting back into
services possibly dealing with
disruptions
in their service if they forgot to opt
back into a service they regularly use
companies are already obtaining member
companies are already obtaining
affirmative customer consent for
automatic renewals and other material
terms and conditions
it's done in a clear and conspicuous way
at the time the customer signs up for
the service and this you know we see
that this gives the customers the option
to conveniently continue the service
without the need to take further action
unless um they would like to make
changes to their service or end the
service um
and finally we just wanted to clarify it
was already brought up about this being
generally in addition to 358 a um that
this bill would place new hampshire
businesses at a competitive disadvantage
with bordering states which you do not
subject companies to similar mandates um
it will place a burden on small
businesses who need to develop and
implement a
some sort of contract tracking
and opt-in system um just for their new
hampshire customers
so with that we'll let our written
testimony speak for itself i'm happy to
attempt to answer any questions and
thank you for your time
okay any questions for
mr baker
none
oh here we go represent van gaal
thank you i was just delayed entry into
that i apologize um my aunt died fairly
recently several months ago
and when her her daughter was going
through the estate she found that
several recurring charges to her credit
card continued after her death
how would this bill address that or
would it address that or what other
concerns do we have making this bill
cover eventualities like that because as
far as i know we will all die
sure uh thank you representative for the
question i'm certainly not a technical
expert on the various um ways that
platforms do their
cancellation and notification processes
but i'd be happy to follow up with you
after the hearing with the information
on how our members choose to inform and
work with their customers to end their
services
for the question
thank you could you just give me a
general response to that um
is this something that the executor of
the rest estate typically informs
the the
business of i guess i'm really not sure
what my question is but uh
theoretically you could be billed for a
great length of time after death uh
despite the fact that um
that you're dead
sure thank you again i don't want to
give you the any incorrect information
um on how the process works so i will i
will get that to you
today
thank you
representative terry
uh
now i have two items mr chairman first
two uh if i may uh address miss van
houn's question i served as the executor
for both my mother and my father's
estates
and
when i notified the of the providers
that my parents had died
they immediately removed the charges
on the basis of
her death and um as of the date of her
death
or his death
so that that was not an issue a second
mr czech could i ask
that when we have lobbyists who are
giving testimony that they not only
indicate to us
uh
who they represent but also what state
they're located in
um i think this would be i know we
receive correspondence from the from the
lobbyists but i think this would be a
particular interest to to members of the
public
who do not know for example where the
internet coalition is located
so mr baker can you tell us a little
about who the internet coalition is and
sure awesome new hampshire so i am a
uh lobbyist with rip granite strategies
so just one block down from the state
house the internet coalition is a trade
association that represents internet and
e-commerce
um organizations and i believe they are
and kyle you actually used to have a job
in the state house i did yes for a
number of years i worked across the wall
uh okay so any other questions for mr
baker
uh i assume connie your hands up just
because it's still up
yup all right thank you thank you very
much
thank you i have nobody else signed up
to speak on this bill
so i guess i'll ask any attendees who
anybody who's attendee would like to
weigh in or not if not
i
don't see any hands oh i do
represent abramson you have a question
no i just wanted to make a remark that i
have to
i have to introduce a bill at uh 10 15
so i'll have to step out for a few
minutes well you're in luck because
we're done here and we won't be coming
back until 10 30.
oh that's true
so timing is everything yes
representative bartlett
thanks very much you know i thought
representative terry had a really good
point we
i i think there are many times when
particularly in this remote settings
where it's tough to know where the
lobbyists are coming from um i'm just
wondering if we can make a suggestion
regarding the sign up sheets that we ask
people
where where you know what state they
live in
um because yesterday we had a
you know multiple multiple
people signed up and we're going to have
it this afternoon i think too on uh
right to repair
and i i'm curious to find out
you know where where these calls are
coming from
well it's funny you mentioned that
because uh i when i first saw the
original sign up format way from the way
way way back when the original
was rolled out to it and and immediately
i noticed that they did not have the
mailing address you know they didn't
have that information in there
and um which as i just said you know i
realize you guys are lifting the
senate's model but
and the senate does piece of paper they
do where they don't do cards like we
think cards like we do and i said i i
think it's very useful um but they know
what we all kind of noted was oh but we
do ask for their phone numbers
so that sometimes we can get a little
bit from people's phone numbers but of
course uh as if it's present company
included there's some of us that do not
have a 603 phone number and uh so but i
would notice that
lately all these sheets that are coming
through for me
they nobody's filling in the numbers at
all so i get it
no and even i mean the phone numbers
we'd have to call them during committee
meeting right that's impractical
so um it is it is true that in this case
the these people are sending um
a uh
their testimony ahead of time in which
if we got that or we print that out we
would see it
now um which representative terry's
pointing out is that the public doesn't
know this
and um and so
as much as you might you were not so
happy with how sometimes i've tried a
little be you know casual about who the
people are coming in but i know a lot of
these people and i try to you know let's
let people know like just for instance
for kyle you know i knew that he worked
with the senate for many years so i
wanted to you know kind of bring that up
and try to let people know that if i
know this person that there's a reason
why i know them because they are regular
lobbyists that their regular people are
here but it is true um it's not been as
much of a problem for this committee but
for other committees they are just
overwhelmed with people from all over
the country who are right and even when
the public are speaking i i think we
want to know where they're from yeah no
i i i appreciate that very much so but i
don't i mean i don't think we can change
anything this year but if you know in
the in the future i think it would be
good for us to you know have an idea i
could certainly it is true that when
when i would read a pink card i would
often say who who they're representing
and what their position is on the bill
so i could be a little more vigilant in
especially when i because when i saw
internet coalition i never heard of the
internet coalition no right neither
certainly you've heard of wrath
pignatelli yes
okay
yes well mr chair of if i'm hearing this
accurately
there's a deficiency or a defect in the
form
from my point of view because and
representative bartlett and perhaps
yourself because because the form
that is used throughout the house is
that correct does not ask for
the uh the location of the
uh of the lobbyists uh affirm
so the burden falls upon
you mr chair to have to remember
to do that if we're going to
informally adopt the practice
of asking not only the identity of the
person
who the person represents but where the
firm is located
unfortunately the burden will fall upon
you because
the forms cannot be
changed um until
uh until next year and and i want to
make clear i'm not and i think it's it's
become clear here there's there's no
intent on my part for us to be mining
for such information because we're
provincial or parochial in our outlook
but rather
that we really need to know
um
where these people are coming from thank
you sir
bro well like i say it's um um when we
when we eventually get back to the house
you'll see the pink card
and the pink guard definitely asks for
all this information so
i'm assuming that once we're all back in
you know
this whole
thing will disappear so once i've had it
down perfect to a science and know
exactly what to say and do
we'll have gone back to the old ways and
but i i would say there there's some
pleasures and minuses about this
pre-registration um you know i like the
idea that it gives people an opportunity
to upload their testimony so it makes
the clerk's life easier
um so there are you know i'm good or bad
but uh who knows what's going to happen
in the future yes go ahead
and regrettably sir for
some of us who are um who are new
uh newly elected um that to which you're
referring pink cards
um we've never seen such things so we're
really operating at a deficit having
never been able to meet in person before
thank you
right exactly but uh you know we've had
our we only have our pros and cons of
pink cards um
the uh sometimes we lose the pink card
because the other someone puts it in it
at the beginning of the room and by the
time it gets past all around it gets
lost and you know so pink cards are
it's sort of you know another one of the
running jokes where where we always just
said we have you need to unmute well the
joke is a lot of people will come in and
especially the sponsors and start
testifying and and the the
german has to ask him to fill out a pink
card because they forgot to do one or
senators senators are terrible they
don't they don't get the pink card thing
at all
right so
so it's just like on mute
yes representative burroughs yeah just
quick question so hypothetically if 300
people from california signed up to
speak
on a bill on our committee they could do
that theoretically that could happen
well
that could happen
on hb overt education they had
[Music]
a ton of out of state people signed up
so yeah now we're we're very fortunate
we we've got off lucky uh compared to
other committees in terms of this signup
sign up system but
but we've had some bills where we had
200 people signed up right you know we
did it you know and i to me it's great
you know the fact that 200 people can
you know get on board and and be able to
you know it's the speaking part i guess
i would would drive it would you know
bother me only because i probably
wouldn't have scheduled enough time for
having all those people that speak but
but but the fact that we have a system
where people um from the state and
and uh uh
hopefully they break their phone number
in it it says 603 so we know it really
are for new hampshire that that can be a
good thing so uh yes representative
abramson
oh sorry i was just gonna notice uh
right while you were saying it that i've
been to other committee hearings and
they have had you know 100 plus people
signed up to talk
and uh many of them are from out of
state sometimes we need somebody who has
a special expertise in an issue like the
convention estates issue
um
but
in most cases it's uh
somebody trying to influence new
hampshire criminal law or self-defense
law or new hampshire elections law and
so yeah like i say we're we're very
fortunate that we haven't had two of
those problems but so
okay uh so uh we're gonna take a little
break here uh till 10 30 and which we
do our last of our phone
phone phone morning
or internet morning tech morning all
right
so
you
uh
all right
well the hour being 10 30. might as well
get started got keith is here good
all right and
um i want i didn't print out this bill
so
uh who's the brian sponsor this for this
bill
anybody can see on their notes i don't i
don't have in front of me
yeah christian's got her question
okay so jackie all right so let me
okay
good morning representative christian
and welcome to the commerce committee
good morning representative hunt and
good morning members of the committee um
i guess i'll get started uh so for the
record my name is jacqueline and
i represent a floaterial district in
manchester um hillsborough district 42.
we are calling from the social security
administration to inform you that due to
some suspicious activity related to your
social security number we've been forced
to suspend your social security number
we're notifying you that there's a legal
enforcement action filed on your name
for fraudulent activities
we've been trying to reach you about
your car's extended warranty
these are all automated messages that
i've received on my cell phone in the
last six months all of which purported
to be from new hampshire are coming from
603 numbers
at best spam calls like this are a
nuisance and a waste of time and energy
i'm sure you can all relate to wanting
to answer phone calls that you think
might be from constituents only to find
that
it is not in fact coming from from
inside your district
um at worst calls like this can cause
emotional distress or trap people in
costly scams or lead to identity theft
um so in a recent report from april of
last year the call blocking software
company truecaller estimated that
americans lost 19.7 billion dollars to
phone scams in the last 12 months
they stated that the average amount lost
per scam in the hundreds of dollars and
the total amount lost is increasing year
over year and over 60 percent of such
scams are initiated with a robocall
another important negative effect of
spam robo calls is that they erode trust
and legitimate uses of automated calls
such as for emergency notifications uh
school weather closures like i got
yesterday
or public health alerts
it may not surprise you to know there
have already been many reports of spam
calls
related to the covid vaccine
availability
um so this bill aims to accomplish four
things um so first it updates some
definitions related to auto dialers and
phone number spoofing
as our current rsa
359e
has been updated a bit but most of it
has not been since the early 1990s
this would be important to help protect
new hampshire citizens in the event that
the fcc
you know federally adopts an overly
narrow definition which is a fear that
some people have expressed that could
cause robocalls to increase even further
second it requires telecom companies
operating in the state to provide more
tools for consumers to help them block
unwanted calls or numbers that have been
flagged as suspicious um so there's
certainly a variety of apps available
that
say they can do this for smartphones um
i know as a consumer it's really
difficult to know if a given app is
effective or maybe even a scam itself
and i hope the committee will agree with
me that uh it's not appropriate to put
the onus and cost of avoiding such scams
on the consumer
when there's things that we can do
upstream
third it requires reporting from the
commerce department on the prevalence of
robocalls in the state and the status of
mitigation measures
and suggestions for additional things
that we can do um to to protect people
from these things
um and then fourth it increases the
penalty for any entities found
to be illegally conducting robocalls or
misrepresenting their location
and also reinforces the power of the
state attorney general's office to
prosecute and enforce this law without
requiring consumers to prove that they
have been been harmed by these calls so
it makes enforcement hopefully a little
bit easier
so i was inspired to uh to file this
legislation after seeing some from other
states um it's a little bit more modeled
after uh recent laws that passed in
arkansas and new york um so i'm open to
amendments um you know that that could
make it more effective or practical for
our state uh but my main hope is that we
can enact legislation uh to cover the
intent set out on the first page um to
ensure that the citizens of new
hampshire are protected from illegal
robocalls and ensure that the scammers
and the telecoms that are enabling them
are held accountable for
for these actions so i thank the
community for your time and i welcome
any questions
so we do have questions if you're
willing to entertain him so uh
good morning representative christian
thank you very much for bringing this
bill to us
um i know it's a tough year to be able
to look at notes from previous years
i wondered if you'd had a chance
to um
to look at the bills that have come up
previously before this committee and to
tell us how different this bill is
from the other bills
so i i have to admit um i've
not done as much homework as i had hoped
to um when i initially filed uh
this bill i was hoping that that ols
would um
contribute that part i i should also
mention this is uh probably like only my
second bill that i've prime sponsored
ever so please forgive me for um
for any mistakes there uh but yes i
welcome
information about about how this would
differ from other things that come up in
the past so further question you may
inquire thanks very much mr chair i'm
sorry to put you on the spot because i i
do understand what you're saying um i
mean one of the things that we struggled
with in this committee
is how
does this bill
um i mean you're gonna get there's gonna
be a lot of other testimony behind you
but how does this bill address
out-of-state companies
um
the fact that spoofing
goes on constantly i mean it's like if
if they find it in one call all they
have to do is disconnect that and start
something else the technology
is very sophisticated to be able to do
this how does that
this bill
address it
yeah so
um so i am aware that there's a lot you
know happening at the federal level to
to try and um
go after
i'd say things that are initiated from
um you know from overseas um
i think the the part about making
i guess making more consumer tools
available um is is in part
a good way a good way to address this so
yeah so that you're you're getting
around um the the sort of constant um
technology if
if people crowdsource and report uh the
spoof calls and have the tools available
to actually block them um hopefully that
thank you thank you i i know i'm putting
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um you said that this is based on model
legislation implemented in both arkansas
and new york uh do you know of any case
law i guess the new york law just passed
in 2019 so maybe it's too soon
if there's any case law on this where
the courts have looked at this and and
brought up any constitutional issues or
due process issues
um
i don't want to
say something that i i can't back up i
want to say i i saw something about it
having held up in court but um
i don't want to commit 100 to that so
i'm sorry i can't answer that question
and uh follow up for the question main
choir
um so this is this applies only to
uh
again companies in new hampshire so
out-of-state
uh out-of-state robocall companies um
it
i i guess my concern is we might be
offering uh uh a false sense of
protection against robocalls when in
fact most of the robocalls come from out
so
scroll down here um i mean the section
on
sort of strengthening the prosecution
doesn't um
sorry it's not meant to to be restricted
to
only calls coming from inside the state
i mean that's
that was the whole
idea was that it should protect people
in the state from calls coming outside
and um certainly give the attorney
general more power to escalate
um
cases up
outside the state just if that makes
sense
yeah
okay i wonder if we could just roll
we'll call him right back
right
okay
uh representative burroughs has a
question
um thank you for taking my correct
question um it's a two-prong question
i'll start with the first part i'm not
clear under um section 10
uh part p it says the department shall
adopt rules under rsa 541a what is the
department i looked at the rsa briefly
and i not clear which department you're
referring to leave the commerce
department
actually looking at that yesterday too
um
we can have a commerce department but
it's okay
follow up right yeah the question may
include yes my the second part of my
question aside from not knowing which
what the department is um
it talks about all these um issues that
need to be reported is it is there do
you have a does it look like there's
been a fiscal note on this is that
correct
that is correct um that was not done
okay thank you
okay uh representative mcclaire
yes thank you mr chair um
i don't understand how we could enforce
this i mean i get i've got that social
security call many many times i i must
admit if i'm
driving in my car
i have fun dragging them on for 20
minutes giving them phony social
security numbers and you know at the end
uh you know telling them where to put it
but i mean how are we gonna find that
person i don't think we can
so
um
my hope is the testimony that that
follows me will have more details about
the technology that is available um
there is some technology available to
to kind of trace the other ends of um
these calls to to my knowledge um
but yes it is a moving target
i guess the hope is that
if we can find some folks and hold them
to account perhaps that will be a
deterrent but um
yes obviously this is a challenging
thank you so much for your testimony um
my question is
um
knowing that it's difficult
to enforce this
or to investigate it and enforce this
nonetheless
is it not true that if we don't have a
law
in new hampshire and we are able to
identify the source of the call
there would be no way that we could
prosecute
um because we wouldn't have a law so
therefore
is that is that a reason why you
one reason why you've uh
submitted this bill
yes i believe that that's a good summary
of uh one of the concerns anyway is that
that yes we need to have something at
least saying that this is not legal so
that we can prosecute it even if um the
technical details are challenging
thank you
okay
thank you very much for your testimony
uh chair we'll call on brandon garden
and you just have to unmute yourself
brandon yep there you go perfect oh
i like that green space you had the last
time now i see you're right you're in
your desk now
well good morning again ladies and
gentlemen and chairman hunt thank you
for for having me again and giving me
the opportunity to testify on this very
important issue
for the record again my name is brandon
garad i'm the chief of the consumer
protection and antitrust bureau at the
new hampshire department of justice i
would like to clarify having reviewed
the bill
specifically defined in this bill and
the testimony that we're about to give
is because the department as defined by
this bill does refer to the new
hampshire department of justice
so
i i i appear before you as as a neutral
party on this bill
um i'd like to
first speak to the issue of robocalls
because robocalls are not only a
statewide problem in new hampshire but a
nationwide problem
not only are they annoying and
disruptive but they're illegal um in
many contexts
scammers use robo calls in order to
solicit people's hard-earned life
savings
and really to take advantage of people
that are put into an unfortunate and
vulnerable position
through the use of robocalls
this has been a top priority for
attorney general mcdonald as well as
this bureau in the past several years
combating robocalls through
as much consumer outreach and education
we're we're admittedly a little bit
hamstrung by the pandemic right now and
our ability to get out there
and spread the
the information to people but we have
continued to do the best that we can in
terms of issuing regular you know press
releases
constantly you know speaking to the
media to try to warn people about scams
doing as much consumer outreach as
possible um really trying to get the
word out about robocalls and about the
scams that are out there to give
consumers the tools to hopefully protect
themselves from becoming a victim of
these really terrible invasive and
illegal calls
additionally you know this uh office
under attorney general gordon mcdonald
has really taken the reins nationally
and has worked very closely with a small
group of states including north carolina
to lead the charge
that brought the state's attorneys
general and the u.s telecom companies
together to start talking about how
we're going to solve this problem and
because the reason it requires the
meeting those two parties is you know in
order to really solve this problem which
i'll speak to you know some of the
challenges of doing that in a few
minutes is going to require a
technological
fix
the ability to stop the calls from
coming in to this country because as
i'll speak to the majority of these
calls coming from outside the country
and it it's going to require u.s telecom
to take steps to change the way their
networks work
to do everything that they can to make
sure that they are protecting
not only new hampshire citizens but
united states citizens from these
again educating consumers is a great way
to prevent these that we have the
ability to do
the more people know
the more people change their it's
unfortunate that we have to live in a
society where you have to change your
habits in terms of how you you relate to
your phone but a few small steps things
like not answering the phone if you
don't recognize the number um
never giving out personal identifying
information if you don't know who you're
talking to and absolutely never sending
money uh never sending money whether
it's by gift cards money transfer credit
card number anything to somebody that
you don't know uh
if we as a society adopt that mentality
would take away all of the robocaller's
power and if people stop responding to
robo calls eventually robocalls would go
away
we like to think we've made some strides
in educating people but is no small task
and it's not going to be a quick fix
and we continue to we look forward to a
day where we can get back out into the
community in person and educate new
hampshire consumers um but we're doing
the best that we can with the the tools
that we have during the pandemic to do
so
with that being in mind i i really i
appreciate the legislature's effort to
attempt to give the state creative new
ways to combat robocalls i think that
this issue affects
everybody in the state and you know it's
it's one of those rare issues is
completely bipartisan it is completely
universal to everybody that owns a phone
owns an email account you know owns
anything
this impacts everybody so i i really
appreciate that we are thinking about
creative solutions to how we address
these problems um i would like to point
i would like to share some information
with the committee my experiences with
combating robocalls and express
based on those experiences um some
concerns that i have with the way this
bill is currently working
so
i believe it was representative abel
asked the question of you know do we
need to have a law on the books to give
new hampshire the
ability to prosecute those that are
making illegal robocalls
it's very important that we do so and
i'm happy to report that we already have
that ability under current case law
both under new hampshire's consumer
protection act 358-a
which incorporates new hampshire's
automatic telephone dialing statute
which is 359e
um currently spoofing any number um
is a violation of the consumer
protection act which is prosecutable
both civilly and criminally in the state
we can take it a step further um the
scams that are being referenced um
grandparent scam irs scams social
security scam any of those what the
callers are doing is providing false
information to people in order to get
them to turn over their money and
that is just plain simple theft
under new hampshire's criminal code
there would be no problem as a
prosecutor if you could identify the
person making the call
that would be a very easy theft by
deception case to bring the problem is
not with the law the problem is with
identifying the individuals that are
making these calls
and you know we we really have
done everything possible to try to
investigate these and try to hold people
accountable but for a number of reasons
that i'll speak to momentarily
it unfortunately it just doesn't work
that way because they're not here for
so
in order to prosecute a robocaller
somebody's initiating a robocall
the person does not have to be in the
state of new hampshire so i want to be
clear about that
new hampshire law would give the
attorney general's office or even the
county attorney's offices the ability to
prosecute a robo-caller who is calling
new hampshire citizens you know using a
robocalling device to come into new
hampshire through a telephonic network
and commit fraud or commit theft we
could prosecute those individuals if we
could identify them locate them and
charge them
the problem is
that the vast majority of them
are located internationally and we have
no jurisdiction to investigate
internationally we certainly don't have
the resources to investigate
but let me give you a little bit of
information on what it actually takes
to identify you go through the process
of identifying
the source of a robocaller
so
as you've noted as you know the the
representative noted and as the
committee knows everybody gets these you
know multiple times a day and they look
like 603 numbers coming into your phone
it's unfortunately not as simple as that
because none of them are actually six or
three numbers they're almost all spoofed
numbers that are coming from another
state or coming from outside the country
in order to determine that
to determine the true original source of
a robocall we need to use a process
which is called the traceback process
and what this is is we don't have the
ability to do it ourselves we rely on
u.s telecom to help us with this process
because it's not just as simple as
all right you look up and find where the
origin of the call came from because
when a call is initiated there are
several different i'll call them hops
jumps that it makes before it reaches
its final destination so it can go from
one network to another network to
another network and sometimes there's
several different spots along the way
before it finally reaches its
destination the victim who sees the
number come up on their phone
so in order to figure out where that
original call came from
first you have to determine the united
states point of entry
so all calls to call from others
overseas need to enter through a point
of entry in the united states um to get
onto our networks
so that is the process where you know a
technological fix would really help to
completely choke out robocalls that are
coming from overseas if you could
implement it and i know this you know
everybody wants it quickly but it's a
very complicated issue the technology
you know needs to be developed and
implemented at a rate that it's going to
be successful and
there have been strides made but it's
just not all the way there yet the goal
is that at that point of entry once it's
gone through several hops
it will be choked out at that point
where it tries to enter the united
states
but for our purposes if this bill were
to pass in its current form it would
anticipate that the department of
justice would be investigating and
prosecuting every robocall that comes
into the state of new hampshire
in order to do that on each call
we would need to take that original
caller the call that came into the
consumer
the date
the time
the number that came in and the
consumer's
caller information and provide that to
us telecom within 10 days of that call
being received because after that the
data is gone
u.s telecom then has to do a traceback
process which
step by step goes through each one of
those hops that that call took
and traces it all the way back to the
original source of the call
this is a very
manual labor and time consuming process
um
that can be done and has been done in
several instances but the problem is
that even once it's all the way done
assuming that you're able to
to get all that process because any loss
in the chain of hops if you you know the
information is lost at a certain point
um that breaks the chain and you can't
get all the way back to the original
caller but assuming that you can
what it will provide you with is a
physical location that is often in
another country
um without providing any identifying
information for an individual that made
the call
or a company that made the call that
could be subject to an attorney
general's investigation and prosecution
when we have tried to trace scam calls
back ourselves internally we've tried to
do it through
um subpoenaing ip addresses
and it takes you know
we issue a spin it's often a month
before we get a result and then the
result that we are able to identify is
the country of origin
and that's where our investigative train
stops at that point
so
we can identify generally what region of
the globe they are coming from
we do not have the ability currently
to identify i mean if they were coming
from within new hampshire we would have
the ability and we would be able to do
this under the current tools that we
have
throughout the history of this traceback
process because we have a assistant
attorney general in this bureau that
sits on a regular
robocall working group with members of
attorneys general from all over the
country uh who talk about you know these
tracebacks where are the calls coming
from where can we identify within the
united states and there have been
sources of calls identified um in a few
states
uh texas arizona um i believe north
carolina zero have originated from new
hampshire
which is great i mean
we that's what we want to hear we hope
that these you know scammers are not
physically in our state it would be
great
to be able to investigate prosecute and
shut them down
but you know similar to
what we've heard before
even if we have the ability to do that
um
you arrest you prosecute somebody else
just takes the place this is not a
problem that is going to be able to
solve by picking off individuals and you
know prosecuting them it's a problem
that needs to be solved technologically
and that's not to say that we shouldn't
be doing anything because if any of
these individuals are ever identified as
originating in the state of new
hampshire
or making calls in a neighboring state
where we have the ability to investigate
this office is committed to a full
investigation and prosecution based on
whatever our resources allow us to do
we would love nothing more than to be
able to identify and prosecute these
individuals the problem is they just are
not in this country or in any states
where we have a realistic ability to go
in and investigate
so
with all of that in mind
you know i feel that i regularly come
before you when i talk about resources
but you know again i would like to talk
about the resources of the consumer
protection bureau
we
do a lot of work on very limited
resources and as a result of that
i never want to say that our resources
are maxed because i want to be honest i
think we could always do a little more
and we tried to do as much as possible
but our resources are very close to
being stretched as thin as they can
possibly go
if this were enacted
and the the legislature decided we want
the attorney general's office to begin
regularly investigating and prosecuting
all of the robocalls in the state of new
hampshire
as well as engaging in rulemaking for
u.s telecom for telecom companies and
also
making an annual report about what we've
been finding throughout the year every
robocall in the state of new hampshire
it would require the cr realistically i
just want to give you my assessment of
what it would take
is the creation of an entirely new unit
within the attorney general's office
that could focus only on combating
robocalls that would at a minimum need
to be staffed by a full-time attorney
probably more than one full-time
attorney but at a minimum full-time
attorney a full-time paralegal and a
full-time investigator
um
and i want to be you know perfectly
honest
in the event that the legislature makes
it a priority to to combat robocalls and
to give the department of justice those
resources to do just that
i
don't anticipate based on all the
information that i just explained to you
that that investment would yield many
results i think that what you would see
at the end of the year is a report that
said we've engaged in numerous robocall
investigations
and they either are inconclusive as to
where the call came from because we
couldn't complete the traceback process
in time
or they originated overseas and we like
the jurisdiction to investigate and
prosecute
um so
that's my assessment i i really want to
emphasize that i think it's great that
we are thinking about new ways to combat
robocalls it's excellent that this is on
the forefront of everybody's mind
because everybody including me and
everybody at the doj is like everybody
else in the state fed up with robocalls
and ready for a solution to this problem
this
proposed solution
i don't think would ultimately be the
most effective one but is currently not
a realistic one based on the current
resources and makeup of the consumer
protection bureau at the department of
justice
so i thank you very much for your time
and your consideration of these issues
i'd be happy to answer any questions
well we do plenty of questions
uh representative burroughs is first
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um you said that this is likely
a techno technic if i can say it
technical logical fix um and so here's
my question i have an app called vmail
and it it screens out about 90 of the
robo calls so if the technology exists
why can't
u.s telecom why can't they implement
something like umail that would save a
lot of heartache for
consumers in new hampshire and beyond
so i i'm not aware of that current
technology so i can't speak to the
complexity of it or the ability of
telecom to implement it on a mass
on a mass market like that i said i'm
just not familiar with that technology
or what it would take so unfortunately
that's a question that i think would be
more appropriate for the telecom
companies and i i don't know that i have
the ability to answer it yeah i know
thank you
okay um i thank you for uh
for your presentation that was uh
i came away
there's no way the attorney general's
office here in the state of new
hampshire is going to
wrap this up i also uh without i didn't
even i think uh i have xfinity but all
of a sudden in the last month
nobody called me uh but uh they they
they uh
you know you get a number
and it says right next to it is
basically
they think it's spam or or some sort of
you know fake
and i haven't i didn't do anything i
didn't do an app i didn't i think it's
just been put into my uh system
in xfinity and um
it uh i don't know how you still just
some of them still get through
but i would say
you know you just heard
uh i i
i haven't heard of that app but i i know
i have one just like it and it it's on
my system
and i would say uh four out of five
um
[Music]
you know whatever the calls were
uh get marked
and so
i think that i think that's where the uh
the uh solution is going to come from
and i agree with uh
um
who's talking barrels was it
uh what's your question chris uh mike
well
i said do you know well yeah he should i
just saying i'm saying would you believe
there is a solution here
uh and it's already being applied
um
and that's it i mean i i i liked your
presentation it was nice i i get your
enthusiasm
but it was uh i think i think it's going
to have to come from
the telecommunity you know the major
companies
not
would you believe so you don't have to
answer that would you believe yes
representative abramson
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um isn't it the fact that um
uh part of the reason for making
something illegal is so that if somebody
uh has a cause of action if somebody
sues for example in another state or in
um
international tort case
that they're able to pursue
punitive damages based on
the fact that the harm caused is not
just caused by the actions of the person
that you're suing
but based on evidence that they've also
violated some law in the process in
other words
uh passing this you're saying it'd be
difficult
to go after a lot of interstate and
international cases
um but wouldn't this also help or
wouldn't this bill at least help people
who are
uh trying to pursue this in a civil case
so i i don't practice we do have civil
law enforcement authority here in the
department of justice but i'm not a
civil practitioner by practice
i don't practice private civil law so i
can't speak too much to that what i can
say is to reiterate that to the extent
actually
having a law that you know makes
robocalls illegal
is the concern we already have those
laws in place
robocalls
that use any form of spoofing or
manipulation are currently illegal in
the state of new hampshire
any call whether it's a robocall or a
manual call
that
presents a consumer with false
information in an attempt to trick them
into giving over money or personal
information
is theft in the state of new hampshire
and is also in you know to the extent
it's done in commerce could be an unfair
deceptive act or practice under the
consumer protection act so we have
diverse laws that are currently in
effect that
in my opinion make all aspects of
robocalling uh
illegal unless it's engaged unless they
register for you want to do robocalls in
the state you have to register with the
consumer protection bureau
you have to pay an annual fee
and you have to use it for a legitimate
purpose as long as you're doing that
your robocalls are fine but any
robocalls that occur in the state of new
hampshire that manipulate
trick the person into you know answering
the phone based on where the call is
coming from
do any sort of spoofing or have any sort
of fraudulent intent are already illegal
of the state
follow-up
further question may inquire
um aren't but aren't there other cases
that uh i guess i'm sounding
argumentative aren't there other cases
that uh wrote that are robocalls that
may be international that aren't
spoofing there aren't fishing that
aren't getting at your personal
um
information or getting at your money
but they could still be either
borderline harassment where
the harm caused may trigger a civil case
but it doesn't rise to the level of
doesn't yet rise to the level of
uh criminal prosecution where it's still
a series of robocalls where they're
calling you same companies calling you
from
out of state over and over again and you
want to take them to court
to enjoy them from doing it
and
if the company is not registered with
the consumer protection any trust bureau
then that is an unfair and deceptive act
of practice in the state um if they are
registered and they're abusing
you know they're engaging in you know
aggressive
um robo-calling for a you know
legitimate purpose
um
that could potentially be an unfair
deceptive action practice depending on
how often it happens and what tactics
they're using calls
the point is that in order there are
already laws that define when somebody
can do a robocall in the state and as
long as you're complying with them
it's not currently a a violation but
any
attempt to use the robocall you know for
a harassing or a fraudulent purpose is
already against the laws of the state of
new hampshire i can't speak to you know
what you would have to prove in a civil
case because i'm just not sure uh other
than you know consumers can bring a
private right of action on if they
believe there's been a violation of the
consumer protection act
and so if somebody were calling from out
of state and hadn't registered and
continued to call a new hampshire
consumer that law is already in effect
that would enable them to to bring a
private right of action similarly if
somebody was registered but harassing
over and over and over again you know
calling to the point where the consumer
believed that you know this amount of
harassment really i think it rises to
the level of an unfair business practice
i would like to hold this company
accountable they have the tools to do
that under the current law
yeah so i hope you get that max because
it i know i tried to explain it before
but having random online i want to
reinforce it that under 358a the
penalties of 358a are a that that the
attorney general's office can go after
you
or
you have the right of private action and
get triple damages
that correct bret yes
all right fair enough okay okay
representative michael here
uh yes thank you sir uh
i've got a question i i obviously that
the social security call the the amazon
call the irs call are very easy to
figure out that they're
they're bogus
but i get a lot of calls from from
veterans uh
folks police fire fire department even
uh you know political uh
parties asking for money and i'm
suspicious of that but then again it's
it's sort of a legitimate
cause in the other hands
do you have any idea whether those tend
to be phony as well
so
what i can give you is my general advice
that i give to everybody who you know
has questions about whether a call is
legitimate or not
which is that if you receive a call and
somebody's asking you for money any
context unless it's you know somebody
that you know you can confirm you know
the identity it's your your wife or your
wife's family or your brother or
something like that your best friend and
it's a confirmed number and you
recognize his voice uh
even then you should be suspicious but
unless it's one of those types of
persons you should be highly highly
suspicious if somebody's soliciting any
type of money from you over the phone
but to the extent that you feel you know
we'll use a police association because i
actually got one of these calls on my
way into work i violated my own rule
which is never answer your phone if you
don't recognize the number i was
expecting a call from my vet so i felt
that i needed to answer it just in case
but i was driving in and it was a call
that said you know this is the
police officers association of such and
such
to the extent that you know you feel
wow if this is legitimate i'd really
like to contribute i'd really like to
know more about this
get off the phone and research it
yourself is any legitimate charity any
legitimate
requester of funds
should have information out there that
allows you as a consumer to make an
informed decision about whether it's
legitimate or not and if there's any
sort of immediacy you know you have to
make a decision while you're on the
phone or you have to give right now
there's no reason that any legitimate
charity or any legitimate purpose would
put that burden on a consumer to make a
decision so quickly
you have the ability an enormous tool at
your disposal in the internet
to thoroughly research anybody that's
asking you for money and to make a call
on your own so that you know what number
you're calling
you know who's on the other end of the
phone to find out the information that
you need to know the point is you just
can't trust
anybody can say they're anybody on the
other end of a call that comes to you
if you take the power and you make the
call and you do the research then you
can be certain that you're talking to a
legitimate source on the other end
could i have a follow-up question
further question we inquire
oh
so these people would have to be
registered wouldn't they
could we ask them what's their
registration number one of the things i
do is i say if i think it might be
legitimate i say look i don't get my
credit card over the phone
if if you mail me a request i'll i'll do
something about it and of course then
they say well i'll let you talk to the
boss and of course they ask you for your
credit card again
but sometimes i've actually gotten a
mailbag so uh
but
it'd be great if there was a registry
that we could look at to see if these
guys
have registered to be a robocaller
thank you
so you can always you know if
in order for it whether it's a business
or it's an individual
if they're legitimate and they are
registered to do business in the state
of new hampshire they should be able to
provide you with that information you
can always make an inquiry to this
office and say you know i've received
this call i asked them what is the name
of the business or what is the name of
the individual that registered in the
state of new hampshire that makes this a
legal um
robo-call
and we can tell you i mean we we we have
a registration i i agree with you it
would probably make more sense if it was
published and readily available on our
website um our website is something that
we're always striving to improve and
that is a recommendation that i will
take very seriously i think we probably
should be publishing it to the public
but
um
currently you have the ability to to
call the consumer protection hotline if
you have any inquiries and you know you
you can ask and we'll tell you if a
business is registered with us or not
and if they're not it may be something
where it makes sense to file a consumer
great representative van gaal
thank you mr chair and thank you for
some incredible insights
this bill represents i think a herculean
effort
on the part of representatives
um looking at an issue that's really
been bothersome for most of our
constituents and i i applaud that and um
and i know she mentioned something like
19.7 billion dollars in losses i mean
it's an incredible problem
uh given that this bill may not be the
actual tool going forward waiting for a
technological fix is there anything that
we can do legislatively that will help
to support your efforts to cut down
robocalls and the scams that they may
represent
you know it's it's a difficult question
i i don't know that i can answer it on
the spot today i didn't come prepared to
to answer that question
there may be i mean i i'd be i'd be
happy to to take that question and you
know schedule a meeting to talk about
this at some point once i have the
opportunity to spend it our attorney
general is in a transition phase right
now we're going to have a new attorney
general soon who's going to have the
ability to set his or her own policies
and priorities um but those types of
reach outs from the legislature we
welcome that we we would love to to have
those kinds of discussions and have the
ability to prepare and think about you
know really is there a legislation it's
not going to be a fix but is there
anything that we can do as a state to
have better protections for our citizens
we would be happy to be involved in
those i believe obviously would be
subject to the decision of a new
attorney general but i i would hope that
he or she would be as open to that as
attorney general mcdonald has been and
certainly this has been a priority of
mine as the director of the consumer
protection bureau so
thank you i think that's an incredible
way for us to
to network when we see something that
isn't quite what we can use today but
maybe there are things that we can do as
we work towards something stronger uh
thank you very much
you're welcome
and representative
and i applaud um representative van
halen's um
thoughts there um
one of the things i have to uh thank you
um attorney
garage on is bringing this coming before
us year after year after year because
this bill comes up year after year after
year and the answers are are pretty much
the same
do you use um
do you recommend charitynavigators.org
to anybody um we were having a
discussion about um solicitation from
charities
i
so i i'm not familiar with that website
but what i can say is that there if
there are any concerns about charities
in the state of new hampshire the
department of justice has a charitable
trusts unit
that is that's what they do is they
register and regulate charities within
the state of new hampshire so any
questions about the legitimacy of a
charity
you can contact our charitable trust
unit here at the attorney general's
office
that's what they do i'm sure that they
would be and i would i would i'm
comfortable recommending that you do
that instead of relying on the web
website that you recommended might be
great i've never been to it um
used it for years uh they they um
they rate charities but that's uh aside
from the point of this bill
um
i'm sorry
um thank you mr chair
um
you identified that we already have laws
in place
to
um
prosecute individuals or groups
that um may be trying to um
befriend
and defraud people um
they're really are you um
it's very hot is it very hard to
um
legislate
annoyance
i mean for in many cases
when by the time it gets to you
it's a crime
but for a lot of us
this is an
annoyance that goes on day after day
do you have any suggestions on how we
can talk to our constituents that this
may not be
a law that we can
practically make
but
other than
you know not picking up the phone
um when we're all
we're all tempted to pick up the phone
even when we don't know
who it is behind it depending on the day
you know like you just said you picked
up one on the way home way away to work
this morning um
is there anything we can tell our
constituents to say
we can't really make a bill on make a
so
i wouldn't say that you can't make a law
because that implies that there's
nothing that the law can do to address
this and again you know there are
already current laws on the books that
address this
i don't i think it may be more accurate
to say that there is no quick
legislative fix that can be enacted that
will make a significant impact on this
problem the calls are going to keep
coming
but there is a definite correlation and
you know
given that you know i answered a call
this morning i i
acknowledge the temptation to answer
your phone
but there is a definite correlation
between how often you answer your phone
and how many robo calls you get
that's very interesting i wondered that
myself okay i am not nobody can be
certain exactly how it works
but those who frequently answer
robocalls seem to be on a list
of targets people that because this is
it's unfortunately
it's a full-time job for people that are
engaging in these scams they have made a
career out of taking advantage of people
and like any you know
like marketing like business like like
anything your target population are
those who are most likely to
subscribe to your business in this case
the business of fraud um people that
aren't answering the call aren't worth
the same amount of calls as people that
are answering the calls so if you're
flagged as somebody who is a likely
on the phone person because if they can
get you on the phone they can convince
you of anything if they can't get you on
the phone they have absolutely no power
to do anything to you it's just as you
said it's an annoyance because your
phone is ringing and it's it's annoying
i mean there's no other way to put it
but
if you can
adjust your practices
so that you
are not picking up the phone unless you
recognize the number or you're exp you
know obviously there's exceptions if
you're expecting a call and you're not
sure what the number the call is going
to be coming from and it might be an
emergency you have to answer the call
but in any other circumstances if it's
important
they're going to leave a message and you
can call them back and you can even
confirm that you know whoever it is that
might be calling you
if it's somebody spoofing them or
pretending to be somebody else you can
look up the number independently and
call the number that you know and trust
if you adjust your cell phone use or
your home phone use to subscribe to that
theory which is that you don't
answer a phone call you don't recognize
the number four
you let it go to voicemail if it's
important enough they'll leave a
voicemail and you don't trust the number
on the voicemail necessarily but you
call back you know your known number for
that person
or that business
i think you will see that the number of
robocalls that you as an individual get
go down it has worked with me
um i get it i have a state issued cell
phone here
when i first got it i got three times
the amount of calls on my state-ish
state of new hampshire issued cell phone
that i got on my personal phone
and because i was i'd love to tell the
story so i'm glad i have the opportunity
to tell a story you know when when i
started here at the attorney general's
office
you know you're a little bit in awe of
working for the department of justice
it's a big responsibility we do a lot of
work there are a lot of really great
lawyers here so you really want to do a
good job so they give you the cell phone
and you get all these 271 you know which
is the state extension recalls
and it says conquered and you're getting
these calls all the time so i feel
obligated you know i what if this is the
attorney general calling me right now he
has something he wants me to work i have
to answer this call so anthony's false
it was i wasn't important enough at that
point nobody ever called me nobody even
knew the number you know i was just some
peon that had been assigned a random
cell phone number but i kept answering
it and i kept getting these calls
eventually i got comfortable enough in
my position here that i realized that
you know if the attorney general wants
to talk to me he's probably not going to
call my cell phone he's just going to
ask him to come up to his office or
anybody else here same thing so i
stopped answering the phone
if i didn't recognize the number if it
wasn't a number that was programmed in
my phone i just did not answer the call
and i barely get any robo calls on that
phone anymore
well thank you for your patience we
really appreciate your input again this
year
okay i got one more hand up uh
you were there
thank you
uh thank you mr speaker i just i just
wanted to ask a question um as to
i i'm one of those that oh i answer the
phone
and i'm not surprised that it's an
out-of-state number or whatever
because of what i do and all the things
i do
uh in my life um and and you have
friends that uh moved to arizona and
keep a new hampshire number i answer the
phone and i'm just wondering i've i've
always thought that there's certain
things you can do
to at least mitigate
the potential
harm that may be done to you and i just
wondered if if
your opinion on
for instance i've always been told don't
say yes oh boy don't say yes um as an
answer to to the person because they can
take that as a commitment
or um
or ask them some questions
or like someone said uh please send me a
request in the mail
um
what do you suggest as things to do to
to help protect yourself from having
signed up for something or
expose yourself to some sort of harm
well again my
my number one recommendation would be to
not answer the phone
you know if it's your friend from
arizona that's kept a new hampshire
number and they're trying to get in
touch with you they'll leave you a
message and ask you to call back
if you answer the phone
you never know
what information you're going to
inadvertently give them that will give
them the power to take advantage of it
however
if you uh insist on answering the phone
and you're going to continue to answer
the phone
all you can do is be aware that if you
don't recognize the number there's a
very high probability that the person on
the other end of the line is a scammer
anybody that you want
to get calls from that you trust put
them into your cell phone so that it
comes up you can trust that's the person
calling and then if any time you're
getting a call from any number that's
not a trusted number in your contacts on
your phone just be suspicious
be aware that anything you say you know
may create
problems for you down the road any
information you give even if it seems
harmless at the time could be part of a
bigger scam that is specifically
designed to get you to say yes or to
give information that you know seems
harmless at the time but is going to be
used against you in ways that you can't
even imagine
these scammers are very good at what
they do it's very high tech and it's
very complicated and you know they're
they've made a whole business out of
this but
if you're aware and you're educated
about the likelihood that somebody else
is trying to scam you and you either
don't answer the phone or you say as
little as possible and get off the call
as quickly as possible that's the best
but again i i highly recommend
taking the time to
really use the contacts feature on your
phone and put anybody that you expect to
get a call from in the near at any point
in the future that's a trusted source
put their number into your phone
manually so that when you get a call
from that person you'll know that it's
them and you can answer that phone with
confidence
okay thank you very much again
attorney garrett and appreciate you uh
help being there for us today so happy
to do it thank you for the time uh chair
we'll call up uh
eric gallagher who uh is
representative gallagher okay sorry yeah
representative gallagher
and
good morning
uh good morning i am here to
testify in support of this bill
um
so a lot of the discussion so far has
been centered on
cell phones um
which had have tools on them
um to
like the
previous testifier was describing
to um block stuff which i i do use on my
cell phone but i'd just like to
remind people of um
that that there are still people with
landlines out there i live in an
apartment building i represent concord
ward 6 which is merrimack county
district 15.
so
i live in an apartment building where
we're required to have landlines
in order to
buzz people in at the door when they
call up
so um
on the landline you don't have as you
don't have the same tools you on a cell
phone to block robocallers
um
and
it's also
also you can't put it on silence or
anything so you have that buzzer
that um
ringer going off so that's like another
effect of it
so um
yeah i just wanted to
remind people of the effect it has on
people with land
great fair enough
you have any questions from any
committee members seeing none
we thank you very much
okay so now we have some
opposition to the bill
and
um
good morning
can you hear me
yes we can
fabulous thank you
good morning mr chair members of the
committee for the record my name is
maura weston and i am testifying today
on behalf of the new england
cable and telecommunications association
um
i listened to you all this morning and i
want you to know that i'm a solo
practitioner based in concord new
hampshire
i'm a new hampshire native and necta is
one of the clients who i currently
represent
nafta's members include atlantic
broadband charter and comcast
which are some of new hampshire's
leading broadband uh and communications
providers
with over 450 000 customers
served in more than
184 communities
although this bill is very well intended
our comments today are in opposition for
two main reasons
first we believe the bill is unnecessary
given substantial efforts by the fcc
ftc
u.s department of justice the state's
attorneys general
and providers to fight malicious
robocalling
second the bill has technical flaws
given subjective standards some
confusing definitions
and we believe unintended consequences
of perhaps making even
routine calls illegal
and also preventing the use of certain
privacy features
that some consumers find important
we've submitted written testimony um for
your review and the record
and it outlines in much greater detail
the protections that are currently in
place and that have been adopted by
voice service providers together with
state and federal criminal and civil
enforcement agencies
to combat unwanted solicitations
necta members for example
have worked to develop and deploy
advanced robocall mitigation tools
this goes to representative herbert's
question earlier
where he notes that he gets a spam
technical standards developed by
industry and now required
by federal regulators lays the
technology groundwork for industry
efforts to fight these calls
and comcast engineers specifically
pioneered what's called
the stir shaken
framework which was certified to the fcc
virtually all residential phone calls
originating on the comcast network
include this technology
and
it is fully integrated with uh at least
12 voice providers including 18t verizon
t-mobile sprint and others
now
what is stir shaken
it is a little bit um beyond my pay
grade and we do include information
about that in our written remarks but
the bottom line
is that stir shaken
digitally validates the handoff of phone
calls
passing through the complex web of
networks allowing the phone company
of the consumer receiving the call
to verify that a call is in fact from
the number displayed on caller id
our written remarks also explain efforts
underway at the federal level
uh including the fcc
the ftc and the u.s department of
justice
for example in 2019 congress passed the
telephone robocall abuse criminal
enforcement and deterrence act referred
to as traced
this is just one effort suffice it to
say that
collective federal interagency
collaborations along with industry
partners have resulted in
very important civil actions
taken against illegal robocalls
in recent years the fcc has taken
significant enforcement actions totaling
over 450
million
dollars against telemarketers for
apparent illegal caller id spoofing
that's just one example and i will
reference you to our written remarks for
more
background on trace and
legal actions taken at the federal
level
and as attorney gerard pointed out
we have our industry has worked closely
with states attorneys general
all 50 states and 12 major voice service
providers have announced a set of
anti-robocall
principles that they've agreed to
implement
or continue to implement for combating
illegal and unwanted robocalls and those
principles are also outlined in my
written remarks i won't take your time
to go through those
we acknowledge that there remain an
unacceptable number of illegal robocalls
but there are robust ongoing efforts
as i've explained at the federal level
and the state level and with industry to
mitigate these calls
to my second point we believe that there
are some significant technical flaws in
the bill
first the bill
really imposes subjective standards
um
you know it uses an unwanted standard
for id and robocalls and i could walk
you through some of the technical issues
again i won't take your time
but those subjective standards
uh
make
this law difficult to comply with
difficult to enforce
etc
further the bill substantially rewrites
existing law
related to the do not call list and we
believe that this diminishes the focus
on malicious robocalls
confuses consumers and potentially
potentially criminalizes legitimate
commercial activity
in fact some of the definitions are just
they're not consistent with current new
hampshire law or for example there's a
definition of telephone corporation
which is not currently a defined or
recognized term under new hampshire law
lastly we think that there are
significant unintended consequences
i have mentioned that this could
potentially make routine calls
illegal um and and also
many consumers like to use privacy
settings on their phones
whether it's for
health reasons family domestic issues um
and so we think that this bill would
actually prohibit the use of that call
blocking technology so for all of these
reasons
um we believe that this law is
unnecessary we urge you to recommend it
inexpedient to legislate and in general
creating a patchwork of state robocall
rules
would be costly
create unnecessary burdens and not
necessarily protect the consumers who we
all
value so with that i thank you for your
time i'm happy to try to answer any
questions
great thank you very much
do we have any questions from the
see now i guess they're pretty
questioned out i guess for
with the attorney
thank you very much
thank you
uh
i'll look over the attendees list or
anybody else would like to speak
on this bill
um
i would um
uh representative bartlett do you
remember liz elizabeth hager liz hager
the representative of course
so liz hager
uh it's been a while she's been around i
think she's like the last republican
that came out of concord but
yeah i think you're right
she actually put in uh legislation
dealing with
um the
unions of the fire department as you get
those fire calls and police associations
associations and it's her legislation
that did uh require them to register
with the attorney general's office um
and that's been on the books so let's
say for a long time uh so those all all
those organizations when you get a call
you say why are you why are these people
calling me i'm on the do not call list
but uh as you probably know nonprofits
are exempt right not call us so that's
interesting because of course she was
mayor of concord too
that's right i forgot to see he wasn't
there
so so they that we do have that statute
um and the um
uh
tom donovan because he he did mention
the charitable trust division they
actually did at one point i put a list
together of all these organizations that
were doing fundraising for phone call
fundraising type things
and um and they were actually they were
interested is how much money actually
went to the charity itself yeah and it
turned out that some of them was like
ten percent it was really uh yeah well
that's that's what charity navigators
helps you with it tells you how much
goes it's
charitynavigator.org
and it's a non-profit that rates
charities
exactly and uh so i would like to be
sure everybody knows that when you get a
fireman's association because i thought
it was weird because i know my little
podunk town you know we don't our fire
department is not unionized so why would
they i'd be giving to a farmer's
association but but they are they are
going to be registered in the state so
they are registered um but even when we
get to the question of charitables and
no and you're asking about how do you
know terrible so any charity that's in
new hampshire if anyone who wants is a
501c or a charitable trust still has to
register with the secretary of state's
office right so anytime you have an
who they are organizat they're fuzzy or
whether they really exist or at least
like who learns a direct phone number
contact information actually you
wouldn't go to the ag's office you would
go to the secretary of state's office
and
the business look up and you can then
type in that name and you can find that
charity and you can find out um who the
treasurer president is and some contact
information uh right
you know what i highly recommend using
that as a resource
for so many of us that are on so many
non-profit boards we know that there's a
you know a charge and we have to make
sure that our treasurer remembers to
right just renew the registration each
and every dollars
yes they have to do it so but at least
it gives a instead of asking the ag's
office which clearly they're over
overworked and clearly yeah
i have to tell you that i mean that
that ag that attorney um
is so patient yeah because they when we
get the same questions year after year
after year on this bill
um and he's very good at
it coming prepared which is wonderful
for us i would have to say that uh he
very well as well very well prepared on
this issue
yeah i'm not gonna take anything away
from the previous people who have been
at that job but no no but he he did he
did have he did do his homework and
okay so uh otherwise we're all set for
this morning and
uh we have our last two bills for
hearings uh this afternoon starting at 1
30 so oh we're going to get plenty of
plenty of testimony on this one to go
skiing and
shoveling or whatever activities you
still want to do um and but it looks
like the sun is shining so it's a good
excuse to get outdoors um i am going to
be introducing the right to repair for
representative luna because he's got a
conflict
um this afternoon okay and it's a it's a
different right to repair bill this year
fortunately i would say it's a very
limited one it's a little more narrower
there's a definitely that'll narrow down
the uh number of people testifying too
really
okay have a good lunch everybody okay
but i'm gonna stick my foot in my mouth
this year yes
ugh
so
you
this
so
you
foreign
so
you
um
so
foreign
hey john
hello
i'm sorry
hi pam sorry i had my emails oh sure
okay
i don't know what somebody's doing
multitasking yeah
you just looked like you were kind of
multitasking
good thing
yeah
so it looks like a lot of people want to
uh
regulate
dog we're muted
dog trainer dog uh
what do i call dog are we muted
no
no you're not you know you're
controlling
you're not you can't hear me
what a shame
we can
we can hear each other we can hear you
and i can hear her
we can hear you christy but
you can't hear us saying that though in
here
your energy's not muted i'd i'd go out
and come back in
but you can't hear us right
right
so
yeah bye bye
start again
i'll email her
christy did i give you enough
information
she's um
evidently her microphone or speaker's
i just sent her an email suggested
i said we can all hear each other
because we can hear each other yeah
right obviously her
some things
but i'm still around
yeah no problem
i'm surprised to see so many bills that
yeah
what what i always said i try to
emphasize to people when they want to
put a bill in
the first thing to do is contact
somebody look up the committee that the
bill go would go to
and look on that committee for somebody
you know
you know don't have to call necessarily
the chairman but but call somebody and
get get the dope and what you know
what's the story why this bill you know
why it is
yeah because it just seems sad that the
same people have to come and testify
year after year on the same bill i mean
it seems like a waste of time for people
yeah
got it
but then again there's some people who
want mandatory auto insurance and will
keep coming back
i didn't i didn't bring it up
right
i'm very surprised that you support
raising the limits because that's really
going to make it unaffordable for for
people who have sketchy driving you know
i mean maybe they're maybe they don't
have an sr22 but let's just say they're
you know that you know they have some
underwriting criteria issues and now
that now that if you raise those we
raise those limits they won't be able to
afford it
and then you'll have less people with
insurance
i'm just shocked i'm just shocked that
you i know and i it's important that i
shock you occasionally
john if somebody keeps bringing the same
bill in every single year just turn it
into a study committee an ongoing study
committee and put them on it
the chapter said i can't know they might
like that
no know
you might want that they might think
this is great i got an excuse to go
ahead
no
i just wish people would call somebody
on that committee that when they're
putting a bill and get the dope on it
you know yeah at least get the history
of what was said previously and what the
determinations were and everything it's
not like that isn't available
i send her a long email
you know it's a rookie
issue
um
and you know she
she said thanks for being patient she
thought ols took care of things like
this she really didn't know how to bring
yeah maybe we could maybe we could talk
to uh ols uh regarding you know these
bills that come back every year or every
two years you know to inform the
the representatives that may be wanting
to put in the same bill maybe it could
be flagged i don't know
i don't think it's their job to
discourage
um sponsors from bringing yeah that's
yeah no but it would be helpful if they
at least told them that there had been a
bill so they can go look up the records
and the testimony and everything and see
what the objections were and you know
what i mean they would be better
prepared they'd write a better bill but
that's what the sponsor should do
their homework yeah exactly yeah well
i don't think yeah
on the committee but you know i i don't
i tell people all the time please call
me in any issue that coming through
commerce please call me exactly and
that's what i said too in her and you
know i tried to be gentle
but you know
i also told her that it wasn't up to ols
to do the research
um regarding the history of the bill it
was really up to the sponsor to look it
up and i know that it's difficult the
lob is not open and all that but you
know when you sponsor a bill you usually
but it was a wasted morning
you didn't think i was going to take a
different position on that did you i i
don't know let's see which one like
maybe
i don't know
no they were all yeah well having the
two sponsors not show up that didn't
help yeah yeah yeah
that's bad form
for sure let me
go
okay so it's uh 1 30 and the sponsor is
here so i will
uh
uh introduce
representative mcgorry to testify in
the j
this has been a tough day for our
sponsors
this one he's got an army of people
131.
he knows we're here he said he's got to
be there unless he walked out of the
this bill was in um um what environment
and agriculture um
last year or this comes from environment
and agriculture
and representative gord
who's a co-sponsor uh was the chair of
that committee last year so i know a
little bit about companion animal
groomers yeah i thought it would go to
ena i was surprised that we got it
do you have an explanation for that mr
chairman
i always thought people send bills to
they send bills to commerce so we can
kill them
well that
dog bill for rent you know dogs and
restaurants bill has come up again but
didn't come to us this year i saw that
it did well no i thought it was over on
the senate side
sorry i thought the bill was on the
senate side
oh you know what you're right
maybe we'll get it later
don't keep breath
great
i'm sorry back
24 to zero
they passed it
and you know and i said to him i said i
don't think they did their homework i i
will profile where were they where would
be the other the people who were opposed
to what are the people who have service
dogs
right
they came in and said it's distracting
to them that's dangerous for them
i've got my notes from last year i just
uh i pulled the files on those
there's a lot of reasons why we don't
want dogs in restaurants
well i don't necessarily agree with you
it's outdoors
the service dogs can stay inside they
don't need to go outside i don't know
come on so this is covered
well i'm post covered i'm sorry i'm not
i'm not going out to restaurants i'm
period yeah right exactly who's going to
restaurants
uh so
uh so i guess we're not getting anywhere
here
and he signed up twice too
um
all right uh let's see i have
can't be too serious about it if he
doesn't show up
he's there he could he's obviously there
he just needs to reboot himself or
something but he's going whoop he's gone
now he's rebooting himself he heard me
good
okay there he is there he is
okay so now uh we you
i didn't i could barely hear you want to
talk louder let me see if i can hear you
no i cannot hear you
so it's not that you're muted i don't
know your microphone is not picking up
what are you using for a microphone
that's what i had done i had turned off
my microphone on my computer can you oh
really you can do that oh yeah
just the icon down at the bottom
but isn't that the mute button no
no no that's your microphone
so you must be a p is that pcs because i
don't have that on my list
yeah
yeah because i don't have that on my
back i don't i can't do that
there's no chat so we can't tell him
what to do right you know we cannot hear
and i will not translate what i think
you just said
he should probably phone in to speak
yeah so what you do is stay where you
are just get your cell phone and
and phone in if you have the
i'm writing him a note
no he's he got it he can hear us he can
hear us no he can't hear us if he's
turned off his mic no no i was uh our
speakers are meaningless
speakers
there he is
okay
good old murphy's law what can go wrong
you get the right phone number
you're
squinting i think he's trying to just
use his phone isn't he to try to call
him yeah he he's still online but yeah
he's he can hear us but he's got his
phone he's trying to
okay he's getting in
getting oh there we go can you hear me
now yeah yeah
yes
i am so very sorry for all of that
confusion i i don't know what's happened
um but we seem to have a problem here in
northampton with a couple of people uh
so again i apologize for causing such a
delay
no problem
great
um so members of the commerce commit
commerce and consumer affairs committee
i'm jim majorie representing rockingham
district 22 the town of northampton
thank you for the opportunity to
introduce house bill 92 a bill to
establish a committee to study best
practices for companion animal groomers
i urge the committee to vote ought to
pass on this bill
this pet groomer's bill was first
introduced in 2019 to the environment
and agriculture committee as hb 376.
it was introduced to create a commission
to study best practices for animal
groomers
the bill was retained in committee an
amendment bill replaced the commission
with a committee
the committee vote on the amendment
amended bill was 17-1 ought to pass h.b
376 has amended passed on a voice vote
on the consent calendar in january of
2020 and was referred to the executive
department's administration uh in the
other body where not for the pandemic
which sent so many bills to the table hb
376 most likely as amended most likely
would have passed in the other body and
finally been enacted
now before you today is house bill 376
as amended reintroduced as house bill 92
and i again urge you to move on to pass
on this bill animal groomers in the
state of new hampshire are not required
to have a license
they are not regulated there is no
governing body to oversee the industry
there are certifications for the safety
of professional groomers and the pets in
their care and numerous regional and
national associations
offering educational opportunities for
groomers
but to date we lack a standard of care
for measures of accountability for
either the professional groomer
or their clients
several states including texas new york
new jersey and rhode island have
attempted to create either a
registration or licensing program for
pet groomers
no states though currently require
licensure for petrol
new hampshire does have though a board
for barbering cosmetology and aesthetics
too and i quote protect the public
health safety and welfare by regulating
the practices of professional barbers
cosmetologists estheticians manicurist
and tanning and
end quote and in quotes qualifies and
licenses individuals and businesses
establishes and enforces administrative
rules and laws and provides information
so that the public can make informed
decisions end quote
if professional pet groomers inspect
animals for skin irritations swelling
cuts hot spots
parasites dental conditions and dirty
anal glands as well as groom different
breeds of dogs according to their hair
types assess the behavior and health
conditions of each different animal
groom large and small animals alike
without injuring themselves or the
animals and recognize when health
conditions should be treated by a
veterinarian i hope the members of the
commerce committee will see the benefit
in setting to task a small
setting a small committee to task on
investigating standards of care and
measures of accountability for
professional pet rumors
today you're going to hear testimony
from joanne schwarpe about her golden
retriever teddy
teddy's tragedy is one in a line of many
many tragedies across the country
exactly like his teddy was entrusted
with a local groomer teddy passed away
while in the groomer's care teddy's
owners and the groomer find themselves
at odds over the health and well-being
of the pet prior to grooming the groomer
and the client find themselves locked in
a legal battle over the responsibility
for the pet's death
ultimately no one is held
accountable result
the loss of a beloved member of the
family loss of professional credibility
and business and no resolution
the study of the interconnection between
pet health
client responsibility and professional
accountability is a critical goal for
the committee committee to study
so again i respectfully ask the members
of the commerce and consumer affairs
committee vote off to pass on house bill
92 i thank you for your time it would be
happy to take questions and again
apologize for the inconvenience
that i caused the beginning of the
meeting
no problem at all
uh so we do have some questions uh first
up is representative abramson
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
for taking my question um i did find a
story cat mysteriously died at pet
groomers got cremated without permission
from 2015 and i guess they're
in the news one of these cases a year
gets reported but uh
my question or i guess my concern is why
aren't there any pet groomers
or would there be any pet groomers
um very good question thank you for the
question representative abramson um when
the bill first came out i think the
intention was to have a larger
commission and and pet groomers pet
groomer association the various
associations that exist might have been
included there however the amendment to
this refine this down from the
commission to a committee so that it
would be members of the house
investigating this i think that those
uh professionals might be included in
should this bill pass
would be invited to participate in the
hearings and discussions but they are
not specifically assigned to the
committee
follow-up
for the question may inquire
uh
i'm sorry this isn't quite related to my
first question but uh
usually what we find is that the
licensing
and certification almost always starts
out privately
and then sometimes moves on to state
licensing
with this commit sorry with this
committee
be free to
consider promoting private licensing
i i would hope that they would oh again
i'm sorry i i thank you for the the
second question i i think that would be
something that certainly would be in
their purview
and uh
i i think representative you and i might
agree that smaller government is good
government and so i would welcome
something that
creates that kind of accountability but
maybe maybe we don't need another layer
of government maybe we don't need
another uh a board or a commission to
look at this but but to but to look at
the entire package in its entirety uh so
that everyone has some level of
protection and confidence i would hope
that they would look at all
possibilities all right thank you very
much
and it's good thank you
okay good to see you
next up is uh representative bartlett
thank you mr chair um
okay i've got two questions
um one is
if there's already a private
certification
i can um i can i think there's one
speaker coming up after me who can get
into more detail but the certifications
would require
um
that you go to uh classroom training i i
say classroom at you know it might be a
little bit different now that we're
doing it on zoom but you need that
specific training in the various types
of conditions that you're looking for on
dogs the various types of
of of of hair and skin types on dogs
some have fur some okay so you you go
through understanding the differences in
the breed you go through the different
cuts
that are available you and and you go
through this process for this
certification
um once
once you are certified i do understand
that you can go to become a
a master groomer which is fairly fairly
expensive and very very rigorous
but doesn't give you but doesn't give
you this type any type of addition
additional licensure it would just be uh
that extra level that you're going for
that extra expertise that you are
getting and and i i apologize that i
can't speak to it specifically it's not
my area of expertise uh but i think we
can ask one of the one of the next
speakers to to expand upon that and i'm
sorry that i'm kind of speaking uh on
the surface for answering your question
superficially
okay could i ask a follow-up further
question me inquire thanks very much um
so as representative um abramson just
said if private
certification if you will
could take the place of
state licensing
would that be acceptable to you
uh thank you again for the question i'm
not sure i said thank you the first time
um
the certificate
i would like the committee to to look at
that to to really understand that
because one of the concerns that i would
have is a consistency it for instance if
if organization a offers a certificate
but an organization b offers also a
certificate in the state of new
hampshire is that the same certificate
are you getting the same training is
there the same accountability uh
available um and not i i shouldn't just
leave this at the
the pet the groomer and the client but
is the facility that they're in also
held to the same standard
do they need to have msds forms
available
does it pass all all
hopefully it would pass all local and
state inspections but i would want to
make sure that there's a consistency i
hope that they would look for a
consistency so that um so so that so
that again we create that accountability
that's universal throughout the state
and i hope i've answered your question
thanks very much
okay you're welcome thank you
representative has a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
a question um
do the animal groomers want this
thank you representative for the
question and i think that's an excellent
question
um and one of this
there is i do have testimony from an
owner
of a of a shop down here where actually
unfortunately teddy passed away her name
is nancy massett and she owns in dog
neato
pet groomers uh she is one of i believe
many groomers who would like to have
this and and and here's the other point
which i think is very very important and
when when this animal when teddy passed
away when teddy shroppy passed away
we were fa the the the owner and the
groomer were faced with the conundrum
who's responsible
so the groomers want this also because
what we have instead of it's a he said
she said we have a standard did the dog
come in exhausted and therefore was at
risk and not the groomer's fault for
passing away so to create again i i
apologize for harping on the word but i
think it's so important to create the
accountability on both sides that it's
mutual uh so i do believe that the
groomers want this for their own
protection even if it comes at the cost
of of a license which may be um you know
i i ventured against maybe a couple
hundred dollars and every every penny
that we spend is important but i think
that kind of
guarantees or accountability would be
valuable i hope i've answered your
question
uh thank you do we have uh or have you
supplied us with uh documentation
indication indicating the the range and
magnitude and number of the problems
that
are prompting you to
thank you representative for the
question and
statistics are extremely important
and i could not find
i could not find and i and i would
welcome this from anybody who can offer
it including some of the other folks who
might testify after me those statistics
which say x number of pets
die annually for these reasons now i i
can say having spoken with this owner
who i named nancy manson she said that
in the state um seven to eight dogs uh
have passed away i think i have that
number right seven to eight dogs do pass
away
uh annually for any number of reasons
why they're in a pet
while they're in a groomer's care
now i i would venture to say is that and
with all due respect to all of us who
have pets is that statistically
uh you know is that within a
statistically acceptable range is that
just what happens sometimes is that
abnormal or or normal
so i apologize that i can't i can't give
you the statistics that we would both
want but i would hope that the committee
then would also be able to get those
statistics or at least be able to answer
the question
thank you for your response
thank you
okay
um have any no more questions we thank
you very much for your testimony
thank you everyone and i i will try to
mute myself
i think you've already done that yes
i've done that
okay so the chair will call on joanne
schwab
and all you have to do is unmute
okay there you go you hear me yes we do
thank you so much um
technical problems here in northampton
but i'm thankfully was able to get in
finally thank you all so much for your
time today i'm i would be happy to
present my testimony um it's not a happy
story but um i think you know it's
necessary to talk about and i appreciate
all of you being here today
i live in northampton as i said and
i'd really also like to thank
representative majori for bringing this
bill back to the table
along with all the other past and
present sponsors of the bill
my family which includes my husband and
our two daughters lost our beloved
five-year-old golden retriever teddy in
june of 2018.
he died while in the care of a hampton
groomer
she left him in an unsafe situation
inside a drying cage with a noose around
his neck he most likely died of heat
stroke based on the necropsy findings
and according to the groomer's statement
to the vet she made a gesture indicating
he may have hung himself
my thought has been that he might have
been struggling to get out of an awful
situation
and the thought of teddy suffering is
heartbreaking and has haunted me the
groomer said she left the building for a
period of 12 or so minutes to pick up
her lunch
there were other dogs in her care when i
dropped teddy off in the morning
she worked alone meaning that she left
all of them unattended as well when she
returned teddy was dead
she enlisted the help of her landlord to
take teddy's body to a nearby vet asking
them to keep him in a refrigerator until
the owner could be notified
she could not tell them how old he was
who his owner was or give them a phone
number because she said she did not have
the information
i had been to this groomer one other
time just a few months prior in april of
2018 so i had no reason to believe that
she would not have my emergency contact
information
i went to pick teddy up at the agreed
upon time
only to meet her in the parking lot as
she was returning from the vet
she told me teddy had died he had
arrived there a healthy vibrant dog that
morning
my own vet was horrified by teddy's
death and took it upon herself to visit
the groomer's site with her manager the
next day
the groomer was on her computer at her
front desk when they walked in with a
dog on a table behind her unsupervised
it had a noose around its neck
she would not let my vet see where teddy
was kept when he died my vet also said
the groomer seemed indifferent and
unapologetic
because the police eventually became
involved the media was notified and took
a special interest in teddy's story
the police and i received numerous calls
from individuals with their own stories
of neglect by this groomer
it was the media interest which was a
blessing and it created a tremendous
amount of awareness in the community
within days of teddy's death i had done
some research and found out that
groomers do not need to be licensed in
new hampshire
i was shocked and in disbelief i also
was unaware that drying cages existed my
impression had always been one from
watching dog shows on tv where groomers
use hair dryers to dry their dogs as
teddy's mom i became extremely regretful
i did not know any of this
as i began talking about this with
friends neighbors and complete strangers
that called me to express their sympathy
i learned that most people were dumb as
dumbfounded as i was
after being contacted by several
sympathetic strangers and groomers i
began my research to get answers and to
see if there could be a path towards
creating some sort of industry standards
and accountability
my reasons for supporting this bill run
deep my family's hearts were broken from
our loss i would not wish that kind of
suffering upon anyone
i have learned about numerous pet deaths
throughout the country sorry
caused by unsafe or neglectful
circumstances while in a groomer's care
i do believe there are many responsible
groomers out there but one unnecessary
death is too many and seven to eight is
worse not to mention countless injuries
sustained by pets during the grooming
process when proper care is not
administered
also of importance is proper sanitation
without which various parasitic
infections and diseases may spread
if there had been some sort of registry
where the many complaints against this
groomer could have been documented teddy
might still be with us
we need to find a way to establish what
should be considered best practices for
companion animal groomers
to try and prevent any future accidents
or deaths with a lack of regulation
there are no training standards to keep
pet groomers accountable
as a native of new hampshire i fully
support our live free or die ideology
and understand that sometimes things can
be overregulated that is not our way but
we do need to protect animals rights
i believe the study would be very
thoughtful way to gain clarity and
establish practices and protocol that
will help ensure the safety of our pets
they have no say in what happens to them
or where they are brought for care
our laws protecting our pets have not
evolved with society and i believe most
people that have pets would qualify them
as family members not personal property
as the law currently states
this will also help rumors and
ultimately protect them as well
we should have a minimum set of
standards much the same as hairdressers
do as one of our new hampshire chiefs of
police said at a meeting that i attended
that same year which was the governor's
commission on the humane treatment of
animals he said rules and regulations
help the industry by making it more
professional while also protecting the
business when something bad happens i
could not agree more
safety standards and methods can prevent
accidents and deaths
this study is so important to our pets
and i fully support it and i ask for
your support today thank you very much
okay sorry about that again muting
mike because my dog was barking
so i'm very sorry about your loss thank
you
um so uh representative bartlett has a
question
thank you very much mr chair
thank you for coming before us antonio
telling us about your story um
oh gosh
my husband's on another zoom too
i'm sorry why don't you let somebody
else go
okay
uh representative michael here
uh thank you very much uh mr chair um
you you said something about a drying
cage
yeah um what what the heck is that can
you describe it
well i didn't know what it was either so
i had to uh google it and um i did get
some pictures from um the groomer that
um jim referenced representative
majority sorry reference nancy massett
from
what actually the actual
equipment that was used on teddy because
we were not allowed to see it
um and they come in various um
forms you can have a it's basically like
a dog crate
with um and they put a dryer outside and
point it at the dog to you know just to
speed up the drying process
um in teddy's case he was in
what looked more like an airline crate
which is you know it's got more of the
hard plastic
which to me looked like an oven honestly
i i feel like he was in it he was cooked
in an oven and that's horrifying to me
but um if it's i don't know all of the
the you know different models that are
out there but it is something that i
feel should be banned i just after that
you know after seeing all these stories
that i you know unfortunately i googled
a lot of this after his death to find
out
um you know just different things that
have have happened and that's a very
common occurrence unfortunately
um so as far as you know as how many
different types and styles i can't
answer that um nancy might have a better
feel for that but i don't know i don't
think she's able to speak with us today
thank you very much
uh now representative bartlett
thank you i apologize my husband's a
aarp tax aide
volunteer and he's downstairs on one
have you have you been able to talk to
the department of ag
um and ask what their position might be
um
it's not really just on the study
committee but you know what what they
might have to say
uh regarding pet grooming because they
do care about um
pets
um you're asking me correct i am thank
you yes i i haven't spoken again to the
committee but when we did speak with the
committee they became quite concerned
when the idea of these zoonotic diseases
being spread um came up that seemed to
really pique their interest
um and you know and feel that there was
a need to really look into this for that
reason um if these groomers don't have
any kind of sanitary guide sanitation
guidelines
my understanding um is you know
and there's nancy's testimony which i
think jim is going to read there's a lot
of references to all the different
things that can happen so from that
standpoint i think they were quite
interested in in you know looking into
this further
ask a follow-up for the question be
inquired thank you um i'm sorry i'm a
little confused um
i was specifically thinking about the
state vet
um
and you're talking about a committee is
there a different committee that we're
referring to here i was talking about
the original committee that heard this
uh oh i'm sorry okay no that's okay but
the state vet did come up in that
conversation as being a
probably a key player for in any type of
um setting up any type of standards for
thank you mr chair and uh i'm sorry for
your loss thank you um
would you be amenable to an amendment
to this where we
add consideration of groups like uh i
guess
the national dog rumors association of
america has uh its own certification
process
maybe even considering that uh pet
groomers have to join some type of
uh regional or national association of
some type that has certification
has its own certification process rather
um i i jim might be able to speak to
this as well i mean my
feeling is that there are a bunch of
different groups out there
and i think
getting back to jim's point about
consistency that's the only thing i
would be concerned with is
i'm not sure
nancy's very very in tune with what's
out there um she she presented
um i don't know if we submitted it or
not but she presented um
i thought if it was the state of
illinois maybe they they actually have
a wonderful set of standards that they
published which we could provide um just
as a sort of like as a frame of
reference
um but i i think that that would be a
start i think my main concern is just
that
um some of them are out there to make
money and others are really out there
because they care about the animals
i mean i'm not saying that they don't
care about animals but a lot of it is
you know some people are in business to
make money and that's what business is
about but
you know if the dogs are in the you know
the
animals don't come first that's my only
concern but i definitely am open to you
know looking into that as well
all right fair enough
okay
um having no more questions we thank you
very much for your testimony
um
now i'm going to call up dara for for
leo
who did sign up and
representing himself and but they are
neutral
they'll
happen
didn't happen
and you're all unmuted so you're good to
go
not having a good day here are
we uh i mean now you're muted yourself i
don't know dan can you hear me
there you go yes we can hear you you can
hear me okay
hi so thank you all um
for allowing me a minute to speak here
on this i i am
not i am neutral against it for um just
with the understanding that groomers
need to have their say in this and that
we're a big part of the process and
there are a lot of us who are for this
um with the right steps being put into
action for it
um i i own a grooming academy in
portsmouth and um we are
are
working with the commit the um
organizations that are all that you're
talking about the national dog groomers
the international society of canine
cosmetologists
we're members of and active in the
an organization the international
professional groomers
most of our groomers here are certified
through them as
groomers stylists
we do a lot of national training and
have groomers from all over the world
and country coming in for us for
training um
we take there is and i'm gonna correct
in some of that
there is licensing in el paso texas
that was just passed uh not too long ago
i was actually there in december
for that and part of that process
um those groomers they do have rules and
regulations and they are being looked at
so that might be something to consider
looking into is the el paso
licensure
and they are working with the texas
association that has just started for
groomers there the woman who is running
that is an academy owner as well so her
and i um work together and and have been
i've been talking a lot about that
we're also members and i'm on the
leadership council for an organization
that's called naga which is the national
alliance of grooming associations
um i presented a lot of this information
when we were in this in
so i think a lot of the information has
gotten around there are people that have
tried in new hampshire to start an
organization
unfortunately it doesn't seem that
there's commodity that that is
amongst the industry and the groomers
working together
so that's been a big challenge pulling
them together and again you kind of
nailed it there's a lot of
diversity in all of the organizations
like joanne was talking about
um
understanding each one and taking it
into consideration now a new council has
been formed and that is called for your
reference the master groomer council and
that is setting the best practices and
procedures for groomers
and that council meets every three weeks
they are working on terminology they're
working on setting guidelines um on a
national level for groomers to be able
to follow and
for that council
your voting rights come as a master
groomer
so any master groomer is able to vote on
that committee so those are the ones
that are are have gone through all the
um
certifications in each organization
so there's a lot to
a lot of
details in our industry certifications
the terms are thrown out there um the
use of certificates and
the
we're trying to grasp the terminology to
get it all together to be able to
okay
uh any questions from the committee
so how uh do you uh as your so you this
whole pet nh that's your your training
academy whole pet age the whole pet
grooming academy yes i i just see that
with your you're like so uh do you guys
recommend this uh
dryer this this try this crate dryer
no we don't train with them we we are
not for um any type of cage drying so
how how prevalent do you think cage
drying is in new hampshire
um i think it depends on
the
every grooming shop does their own thing
so i would say probably here in new
hampshire there's not as many using them
anymore
a true cage dryer is very expensive
uh they cost two to three thousand
dollars
so it's not a a common piece of
equipment what a lot of groomers will do
is use a
fan or
hook up the blow dryers to the crates
or the kennels and let them dry that way
it is very hard to monitor the dog when
they're in those situations
and if you have a dog on the table you
can't monitor the dogs that are there
a lot of drying rooms are separate from
finishing rooms so you have to the a
small shop is going to have a high high
heat humidity in their space with the
water in the dryers
it's hard to regulate the dog's
temperatures so larger spaces cooler
spaces um well ventilated areas
all of that needs to to be looked at
when when purchasing or getting into
shops and and business ownership
right let alone for the consumer to
decide which is safe place to take your
yeah yeah and open concept shops are are
a lot more um looks and and and people
are looking for shops that are more open
and want that open concept grooming
uh representative abramson has a
question
um thank you is uh i've we've gotten a
couple of emails saying that there are
no groomers included on this committee
um
are you saying that there should be
groomers on this committee if it's going
to operate
i definitely would think that you would
want some groomers on there um at least
to have
their input or their guidance um
not necessarily because when we did go
through this process they were saying
that this is going to be a full-time job
i would imagine you have a very brief
time to turn this around and to do this
investigation
so
if
it's a a month period or an and the time
time allowance for a groomer to walk
away from their shop and and give the
time is it's going to have to be a
voluntary position i would imagine
um
to have a
open
conversation with groomers i believe
they did speak on that and saying we
want to talk to corporates we want to
talk to
kennel owners we want to talk to vet
clinics that have grooming shops
in-home groomers mobile groomers
groomers that do
in-home grooming and travel
so you've got a lot of different
types of grooming going on
it's not just a shop environment
all right thank you just uh for the
education of our new members and there's
a there there are two kinds of uh study
committees here in the legislative new
hampshire legislature
um we have what we would call a chapter
study um which would uh would be really
a commission
and in that commission you would bring
in
all the different uh uh people who have
a
players and all the different types of
industry and all the people
on an issue
um
and then you have a legislative study
committee and that's what this is in the
legislative study committee um and this
is classic it has three members of the
house and one senator uh usually the
they we limit to one center because we
want we hope we get at least one to show
up uh because often senators don't
aren't his invested interest in in the
study committees um and these study
committees are are
they're ta the idea is that um all the
players all the people who have some
some interest in in the issue would
normally show up anyways to the study
committees but they don't need to be the
voting members that the legislators are
there um because then you're you're
getting them to buy into the concept of
whatever comes out of that committee
okay having said that uh representative
thank you mr chair uh i think this a
question may be for um the sponsor it's
in regards to the um
membership of the committee we got some
strange noises so dara you might you
might want to mute
um
so i'm sorry say you're you're
was yeah no i was i was looking i mean
it just says three members of the house
of representatives
i think it should be at least one
committee member um from environment and
agriculture
that is true often study committees
with legislative study committees will
identify uh which committees the members
should be coming from
that that is true
right and um just to follow up with that
um it should be one
you know it should be a republican a
democrat and maybe another republican
from both sides yeah generally they
don't do that it's really based on the
leadership so if i had a guess this you
know
um
usually well the senate is you know you
know but usually it would it would be
two members of the house two one member
uh uh who were republican one uh if
given right now the majority and then
but they generally normally would look
at the committee the bill is coming from
but you're right that having the fact
that it's coming here to commerce
rather than having um
have it going it through through uh
the
environment and agriculture or e-dna
that matter because of licensure you
know in terms of whether we should want
licensure but usually edna
licensure is a secondary first we it's
the the committee that's most involved
in the issue they think it's a good idea
then it goes to you dna to they are
going to go forward with licensure but i
it does really beg the question that
maybe the right answer here is really a
chapter i think a chapter study to get
all the players involved um rather than
a legislative one but what is a chapter
study
so a chapter study is a commission
a chapter study would be a commission
and then you have and the problem the
problem with those chapter city
commissions is is that you have a
let's say you have a groomer or someone
appointed by the governor
okay well does the governor get the
appointment done in a tiny fashion so i
assume that they in their wisdom they
thought well this turned into a study
committee to be quick but frankly this
issue is probably more complicated so i
would actually go with that commission
that a two-year commission in other
words give them more time to really
think it through
and have all those players involved who
are who are you know for it and
that might be a better way to do it and
maybe you wouldn't feel the time
pressure uh and certainly would you
didn't want um
people who who are the groomers to feel
like that they have to give their job to
to do the commission
you have further question
well it's just a you know just a
follow-up on the licensure i think there
should also be someone um from the
beauty industry on this committee or
commission because they are licensed and
they're
not
unlike they don't they operate similar
to groomers i hear you but uh you do
know that a couple years ago there was a
big move to get rid of uh that licensure
requirement
represented macular
uh thank you mr chair um hearing about
these cages uh which i had never heard
of before i i googled them
and uh
they're pretty scary um there's an awful
lot that can go wrong um it suggests
that there
needs to be somebody in the room all the
time watching them there suggests that
there need to be a thermometer that you
could
see the temperature at all times um they
scare me
what is your opinion about maybe uh um
one that fully cages a dog that type of
machine
not be be allowed any opinion on that
right so this question would be to you
dara
yes i'm sorry yeah assume you've got
your your dogs okay okay
did you hear the question
i did yes yes so i
um
it's not all dryers but yes those cage
dryers are are very difficult to
to monitor and
you have to have
enough stack and enough education
to know how to use them properly they
can be used properly and i'm not
saying that they should be
but they can be used properly in certain
settings
i'm not training students on them
because we don't
endorse them
so
ever again every place is going to be
different i mean you can can say that
they can't be used and most people i
think would agree or most groomers would
but you're going to have the backlash
from those that have been doing it for
30 years have been doing it for 40 years
have been in the industry and they've
done fine with it
um
it is a very hot topic itself in our
industry
so it's
it's not
anything that's not talked about
throughout our industry and it's one of
the
topics that we will be talking about in
the uh groomer council
[Music]
um all right so i have gone through
everybody who had originally signed up
to speak i have two people who are
who are now asking to speak i would ask
them to i'm going to call up nancy
messette
and then there's another one m fisher
which i'll call on a second i would ask
well i have to wait because i know
there's a blackout moment here
um good afternoon nancy uh you didn't
sign up we are a little bit behind but
so i hope you can
you can uh give us a be succinct in the
there is a delay i don't know this is
the way i tried it this is why i try to
bring people up ahead of time and then
we have not done well today
is she from northampton too
if i could speak just for a minute or
second i don't think nancy is prepared
to she's in the middle of her um
her shop business right now i think she
was hoping that jim might be able to
speak for her she just sent me a text
okay
is that possible well the problem is jim
dad doesn't he has to get on his phone
to get here all right so i'll let you
call it if you want me to roll those
dice i can
uh well you know that time you worked we
could hear you but it was a little
echoing but go ahead
you have you have heard i hope you have
i do i'll read as quickly as i can okay
perfect great
uh so again thank you members of the
committee my name is nancy mastid owner
of indognito incorporated grooming
studio located at 892 lafayette road in
hampton yes the former location of mrs
doolittle's bath house this is the
location where teddy the five-year-old
golden retriever belonging to joanne
trophy lost his life to to unfortunate
and preventable circumstances i have
been in this industry as a pet groomer
for almost 30 years and i was a
veterinary technician for several years
and i am also a licensed cosmetologist
for over 15 years my passion in life is
animals but my heart is in the
caregiving for dogs and cats in all
areas of their lives that is why this
bill is so important to me dogs die in
grooming shops every day of the year
groomers are injured every day of the
year but it should not be from such
things as poor education and lack of
proper training it should not be from
faulty or poorly maintained equipment or
from poor sanitation or improper use of
products or neglect to basic safety
protocols dogs can die from heart
failure respiratory conditions stress
and many more underlying conditions
groomers should always be prepared to
handle these situations to the best of
their abilities and perform education
i.e being cpr
first aid
certified and continuing education
so many people think our job is great
and they think that we get to play with
dogs all day most of us are skilled
professional pet groomers that have
attended schools done long
apprenticeships attended trade shows for
continuing education and more
some groomers go to show go the show
root and some go the max of obtaining
prestigious certifications certification
such as master and try it again
certifications such as certified master
groomers
many of us maintain memberships and
certifications to groups such as the
iscc
in parentheses international society of
canine cosmetology and parentheses
ndgaa
in parentheses national dog groomers
association of america and parentheses
and many others but since there is no
actual licensing for groomers in 90
plus percent of the us anyone can become
a groomer and open an establishment to
work on your beloved pets no training
needed or even more online
grooming
course excuse me there are even online
grooming course options i asked a
carpenter friend to take one of these
courses and so he did he finished the
course in a matter of days and got a 90
to 100
and is waiting for a certificate in the
mail
as groomers we deal with dogs
ranging from three to 250 pounds long
hair short hair friendly and not so
friendly blind deaf missing limbs and
lots of other different medical
conditions we deal with zoonotic
diseases parasites skin issues and so
much more if you don't have some kind of
formal education you are putting your
pet yourself and many others at risk
safety should be the number one priority
in our business i have sent along
pictures of the equipment and the shop
conditions that i found when i went to
mrs doolittles after she closed the
smell alone had me thinking twice about
the endeavor i was about to add to my
already full plate i wanted to create a
safe clean salon with cameras with
camera safety camera systems safe spaces
for pets and staff i gutted the place
from top to bottom and insist on my
staff continuing education even during
these difficult times i wanted to place
i wanted a place that someone like
joanne would know that when she was
ready she could feel comfortable and
safe leaving her beloved new family when
she was gone
um
i understand that attempting to license
individual groomers is attached to great
cost and the time and time so i have
i do have a few thoughts of other
possible options that can start a
process of accountability which is
something groomers do not have and
honestly most groomers do not want
because they don't want big brother
telling them what to do and they don't
want to have to spend money bringing
their facility standards
bringing their facility standards where
they should be i believe that we can
make some of the responsibilities fall
on the individual individual salon
owners including mobile groomers i
believe if we start with grooming salon
registration systems where the salons
are registered they can then register
their employees and that will hold them
to some extent to the liability and make
them think twice for whom they choose to
hire
shops should be inspected at least once
a year i believe hair salons are
expected
twice a year
shops including mobile units will have
to meet certain standards for
cleanliness equipment
and or vehicle maintenance sds books i
think that should be msds books all
employees are current on cpr first aid
certification in our industry the
certification is usually good for two
years proof of insurance proper
sanitation is being done and proper
labeling and storage of products for
groomers that choose to use drying cages
they must be in their sight lines at all
times so they cannot so that they can
monitor the pet's condition
and must be well maintained for safety
reasons many pets die in these types of
cages every year i also strongly believe
that if pets are not kept within strong
sight lines at all times the salon
should be required to have a camera
system in place to maintain safe visuals
on the pets salons should be able to
maintain a good heating and cooling
system that provides adequate climate
control per the square footage of their
space that should not be left alone in
the building unless the facility is set
up and licensed as a kennel
and also meets the established safety
requirements if the facility does not
pass inspection they can be given a
sheet on what needs to be fixed or
changed and given a grace period to fix
these problems or be fined based on the
demerits they receive
what happened to teddy was not only
heartbreaking but completely preventable
he was used and left in an airline style
thick plastic crate with a very
non-maintained dryer blowing hot air in
the front of the crate during the summer
months where he was already a problem
mrs bessemer then left the building for
an extended time we all know what
happened next let's find a compromise to
keep this and other tragedies from
happening again
um there there is there is a bit more mr
chair to uh i probably take me another
two minutes
um
um mr chair uh this is the clerk would
you request please that uh that
testimony be sent to the committee and
i'll i was about to say that thank you
so so jim you
you i know you're signed up because you
signed up twice uh you've that same
thing you sign up to you can go in and
have upload that so that get to all the
committee members
no i will do okay i appreciate that
okay uh representative
said do you have a specific because this
this testimony we just heard with that
person's not here i i have a very quick
question for representative majority
okay sure
representative would you be willing to
bring in an amendment changing this to a
commission
uh two-year commission working with all
the folks that you did
to specify the types of folks you need
on that kind of commission
thank you representative for the
question i'd be more than happy to do
that um and and i would i would defer to
the wisdom of of the committee the chair
about whether that's an amendment or if
you retain this so that can be changed
but i defer and would be more than
welcome to change it to a commission
all right so yes i did get to him and my
preference would be is we would retain
it and then we would create the
commission in the fall and that way we
make sure we cover all our bases
okay so
i'm not supposed to tell you what i
think
okay so
uh so martin martin fisher is the last
yeah you're a dog barking
uh
okay uh
we are behind here um
okay well if you are there and you can
hear me just uh please
put your thoughts on paper and and go
online with the state house webpage and
and upload it and so all the committee's
committee members can see it and with
that i'm going to close the public
hearing on house bill
92 and we had
151 people in support
seven opposed and one neutral
and with that we'll close the public
hearing
and we thank you those of you who it
came to testify thank you very much
and and joanne again i'm sorry about
okay
okay you're probably all wondering how i
can get in front of my desk at the
committee room
okay house bill 449 and the
representatives oh that's right you're
going to do this representative bartlett
aren't you okay
all right uh
uh
keith are you ready to start another
bill yeah i'm just about there uh okay
thanks for
all right ready to go i was a clerk once
hard to keep up
it sure is
thank you very much um good afternoon
commerce committee
for the record i'm representative
christie dole at bartlett representing
merrimack county district 19 in concord
i'm introducing
house bill 449 on behalf of the prime
sponsor representative dave luno who
could not attend due to his committee
commitment
the commerce committee is familiar with
the right to repair
legislation from past sessions which
under both republican and democratic
leadership has resulted in favorable
reports following interim study
concern has been on product scope and
access to proprietary information
whether owned by the user or the
manufacturer
here the scope in this bill is limited
to appliances like washers and dryers
an area that's become very important
during the pandemic
and the bill addresses access to
information on fair and reasonable terms
and only the information necessary to
repair the appliance
you may want to hear from others after
me on the details of this scaled back
bill with details
for your questions
thanks
good
thank you uh any questions for
representative bartlett
i guess oh representative abramson
he's gonna take his chance
so you do realize he's not the prime
sponsor of this building yes
but
i'm going for in intent
uh or maybe just to draw attention to it
it's uh
towards the bottom where it says 358-t
section three requirements part one for
home appliances
um and parts for such appliances sold or
used in the state an original appliance
manufacturer shall make available for
purpose of diagnostic maintenance repair
of such appliance to any independent
repair provider and so on um
uh michael sorry i don't know where you
are oh it's uh
i i have it on the website i don't have
the one where it paid your line
no don't use page online use what the
rsa reference
yeah it's uh
by itself it says 358-t
section three requirements d3 that's the
actual statute yes 358 t
i see definitions
yeah t3 is is the actual
see requirements got it got it okay it
says for home appliances and repair for
such appliances sold or used in this
state an original appliance manufacturer
shall make available and so forth
my concern is we have
in seabrook we have some
second hand
providers and we have people who sell
things second secondhand we have we have
both companies and individuals who sell
them so would that mean that this is
going to apply
uh i believe that it does should apply
if they're selling something
how so how could a manufacturer
if they don't want to comply with this
or not able to comply with this how
would they prevent
those appliances from being sold in new
hampshire
i i don't have an answer for you i'm
sorry i've just introduced the bill yep
um
okay
um all right so uh normally we do is um
uh state representatives first so uh
eric gallacher is that i all i see is
eric is that you eric
eric gallagher if that's you put your
hand up so because you did sign up to
speak
to
uh eric
maybe not okay
so um so the next uh i will have is um
in support of the bill let's see
okay here we go um
all right so this is
gay gordon burn who
is a repair organization and it's in
so all you have to do is uh unmute
yourself yep i'm unmuting and starting
my video yeah you got it there you go
perfect hello
well it's great to be here thank you
chairman haughton members of the
committee um been there before sorry i
can't go and enjoy the centennial hotel
again because i love that place
uh but uh happy to be here anyway
we focused this year okay let me just
back up for those who don't know where
are you from yeah where are you from and
where okay yeah uh gay gordon byrne i'm
the executive director of the repair
association um also known as repair.org
because that's our uh website we are a
nonprofit we're now over 450 members
most of our members are either small
repair businesses or they are trade
associations in the business of repair
and a number of our affiliates are
groups that are more focused on consumer
protection and consumer rights in
general
so i'm here to talk about why we're
talking about appliances and for me it's
because two years ago um i was in
testimony in vermont for this very same
bill that you looked at two years ago
and uh one of the people that was there
was testifying about how people
shouldn't be able to repair their
appliances and the senator said uh well
what's the useful life of a refrigerator
and the answer was 12 years uh
20 years but now 12 and the difference
being that the presence of electronics
and refrigerators has dramatically
dropped the useful life of refrigerators
and that's pretty scary to me as a
consumer
my refrigerator the last one i had it
was 20 or 20 years old when i bought the
house
and uh it did have a failure and i was
able to get a local repair tech in he
charged 80 bucks for the service call
and like 25 bucks for the thermostat and
uh i asked him i said so what about the
electronic thermostats and he says oh my
god they're awful they break all the
time
so i'm like a little bit clued into the
fact that there's a specific uh
durability problem with major appliances
that didn't used to exist
i think they used to be called durable
goods but they are far from durable now
and from the electronics standpoint
they're almost all doomed
because as soon as you put a capacitor
on a circuit board those are essentially
teeny-weeny little batteries those
things dry out they always fail just a
matter of how long it is before they
fail so you're now putting parts that
are guaranteed to fail into expensive
consumer products
and then if you don't make provision for
getting them repaired more easily
they then become a real burden on the
consumer
and a real excessive cost for people
that really probably couldn't afford
brand new in the first place i mean if i
had to put my house on the market and
only sell it with brand new appliances i
think it would be very expensive
and then i'm turning around
and getting a mortgage which includes
the cost of those appliances so it's
very pernicious if we can't repair these
large things
some of them are larger than others
obviously if my toaster breaks um
and i have tried to fix my toaster
it's not the big it's or it's not a big
deal but if my refrigerator breaks
that's a very big deal to me because a i
need to keep my food cold and b i know
that if repair is going to be 500 and
the new refrigerator is a thousand now
now i'm in the market for another
thousand dollar item
um and
not everybody can afford that the other
problem that we're seeing is that with
the pandemic
there's not a lot of repair actually
going on there's a lot of need for
repair but a lot of restraint um you
know technicians aren't traveling
people aren't welcoming people into
their homes they're not able to go to
the store and buy a new thing because a
the stores don't have any uh and for
quite a period of time the stores closed
so
the options have really been shrinking
and if we don't have the opportunity to
repair these things
um and that opportunity has been
shrinking then i think we're really in a
lot of trouble
um
another
problem that's cropped up with home
appliances as it has with other
equipment is that parts are now being
paired
so you could buy a brand new thermostat
from ge a friend of mine did this
go to put it in and have the thermostat
say input password
and since he looks at the packaging
materials can't find the password calls
ge
and says okay i need the password g he
says no we won't give you the password
you have to call a ge authorized service
technician to come out to your home and
insert the password now this wasn't as
easy as you might think because the plot
the place where his refrigerator was in
florida and he lives in massachusetts so
to go let somebody in the door to do a
password thing a silly password thing
was not as simple as it might have
sounded and that is going on very
broadly and it's probably going to kill
a lot of repairs
that are currently available and make
them impossible so we have to anticipate
that the market is moving in a very
negative direction when it comes to our
collective ability to keep the things we
have in use
now just to make it clear because this
doesn't always come through clearly
repair is only restoration that's it
the only thing that anybody needs to
repair things is they have to know what
the error codes mean so they probably
need documentation
they need the diagnostic tools to be
able to figure out what the actual
failure is
i know when my dishwasher broke um i had
a light that said e8 and i had
documentation and said e8 said there was
a clog
and there was actually a clog and i was
able to clear the clog and get the thing
back but if i didn't have that
information i wouldn't be able to do it
i would have had a service technician
come out god knows what they would have
charged
and there's no benefit for me not having
that documentation other than the fact
the service tech who i assume is getting
paid nicely
gets a service call
so you need the doc the documentation
you need the diagnostics the diagnostics
are created
specifically to make it easy
to repair because manufacturers don't
just
have
they have a warranty obligation they
promise that they're going to fix this
stuff for a period of time so their
business model is they have to be able
to support their in warranty service at
a reasonable cost so they create these
tools
called diagnostics to make that easy so
the technician just plugs in the
diagnostics finds out what's wrong
orders the part maybe the parts in the
truck maybe it's overnight maybe it's a
week puts the part back in
reruns the diagnostics to make sure that
the failure is cleared and then that's
it
here's your bill
off you go so everything else that's
what this bill is asking for is asking
for fair and reasonable access on fair
and reasonable prices to those specific
diagnostics documentation parts and
tools that are necessary for repair
everything else outside of that is not
repair it may be frightening you may
hear some really really crazy stories
because we have definitely heard some
um
you know there are some i wouldn't be
surprised at all we used to call it
entertainment hour when some of our
opposition testimony would come up and
start saying oh children are going to
lose their arms getting ripped off and
washing in
washing machines or microwaves are going
to explode or there's gas
gas and you know unspecified gas
somewhere
and those are just a parade of horribles
that
don't actually tie to repair they tie to
frightening legislators and that's their
whole purpose because if people have
access to the same documentation parts
and tools and let's say ideally it's not
in the statute but ideally they should
be able to get the same training or
there can be a trade school that
provides training or community college
that provides training or on-the-job
training this is not really rocket
science
the people that are normally hired to do
appliance repair they're not phd
electrical engineers they tend to be 20
an hour technicians
much like the same pay scale you see in
an automotive
repair location
so um that's what's going on with repair
that's why we need it i own a bunch of
appliances that are really really
overpriced and if i can't get them fixed
um it's gonna cost me a lot so even
though i'm in new york state not new
hampshire if i could buy what i need to
repair my stuff in new hampshire i would
really want to be able to do that and i
think everybody in the surrounding
states would want to do that as well so
i hope you pass this available for
questions um this is kind of my thing
and i'll let um
let the next person throw some things
out
uh we do have someone who wants to ask
you a question yeah so representative
ham
thank you um thank you mr chairman
and thank you for taking my questions
do you know if there is any requirement
for manufacturers of home appliances and
i mean major appliances uh not
necessarily a toaster but
to
have available parts for a certain
number of years
five years ten years whatever do you
know if there's any requirement because
i can give you example um
i i purchased an appliance and i called
a repair man and
they said oh dears too bad you bought
that
product too bad you bought that one
because they they are not good at having
any pots available they don't they don't
make the parts um
enough parts uh to be able to repair um
your particular appliance do you know if
there's any requirement that they
are supposed to
make parts available for five years ten
years whatever
excellent question and to my knowledge
there are no requirements um we believe
that there's a requirement in europe i
think france has some requirements and
those are new coming in
um and oh yes cal california has a spare
parts requirement
but
it's for five years
and since you're in new hampshire not in
california you probably have to go see
if you could acquire that part in
california
but nationally there's nothing um and
sadly i've been in your shoes i i also
have clients
where they mysteriously ran out of parts
uh representative abramson has a
question
uh thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question isn't one of the
arguments for right to repair i i
haven't read this i read an article many
years ago
that it was partly to cut down on
landfill use and
improve improve
improve recycling and reduce the
negative environmental impact of uh
buying all these manufactured goods
um it's a byproduct and a fortunate
by-product because if you can keep your
things running they don't go into the
waste the waste cycle and a lot of the
um waste
is accelerating
because more and more stuff doesn't last
as long as it could i mean what are you
going to do with it with a refrigerator
that you can't fix it's going to go in
all right thank you
thank you
thank you very much
uh i will next call on uh dylan
[Music]
tice
and
[Music]
dylan tice is a member of the public and
supports the
bill uh
they don't have much more other
information so tell them can you
introduce yourself and what your
background is before you
you
you have to unmute yourself so there you
go
perfect all right uh can you hear me now
yes we begin
okay so um
i am a barrington resident in new
hampshire
i came along i figured uh you should
have somebody local
um
currently my my job title is technically
uh engineering technician
uh i do mostly desk work at this point
no no
i actually don't use the phone for
hardly anything i i spent a while
writing procedures and then i went on to
you know configuration
related tasks but
so anyway
i am in support of this bill um
primarily because well i
have generally preferred independent
repair they haven't they have a tendency
to be allowed to do things that
your regular authorized repair
technician would not be allowed to do
like kind of like when you go to an
automotive shop
like you go to your dealer with an
exhaust leak and it's going to be 1500
because the only thing they'll be
allowed to do is remove and replace
well having
having
the authorized repair they have a
tendency to be less bound by the rules
and if parts aren't available they can
do more
but this just sort of brings it together
so they can still actually do
one of the
well most of my concerns have already
been covered by the previous speaker
and
um let's see
well that's good
we're glad you called in and
you're looking at your notes or i i am
most
um
that's
all right well that's great well thank
you very much for calling and we
appreciate in and hearing hearing from
you thank you
oh one more thing if uh
if i'm not unmuted um
as far as the scope issue that we had
before with the previous bill
uh would it be would you consider it
unreasonable to expand that but i'll
make that a voluntary thing kind of like
how um
just like a mandatory disclosure or if
this doesn't pass to do the same thing
but as a voluntary but you have to
disclose that it's not falling within
a fair repair guideline
because as a consumer i'm trying to
navigate
um which products to buy and
usually for the most part people don't
know what they can repair until it
breaks
so if there is some sort of something
that
i guess kind of like when obama came out
though the best thing about obamacare
was that
regardless of whether or not you liked
the bill or not at least defined basic
essential coverage so you knew what you
were getting when you bought it
just having a definition that you know
that they have to disclose hey this you
can't
they put it so they can't put berries
and obstacles into repair
but
you know without us knowing about it
until it breaks
that's an interesting concept
all right well thank you very much thank
you for calling we're
zooming in
okay uh we'll change a pace now and
call on john keane who is in opposition
and he represents the association of
home appliance manufacturers
uh good afternoon uh chairman hunt
members of the committee my name is john
keane with association home of his
manufacturers also known as aham
and we're in opposition of house bill
so where are you from
well we live in ireland dc it's the tc
area that's all sorry
i think the next person is also a dc
lobbyist so this is good to have you
guys next to each other go ahead
um ahem believes this bill raises far
more issues and concerns it seeks to
address
our industry encompasses everything from
your refrigerator your clothes washer
microwave electric toothbrush
with that repairs come with the handling
of refrigerant gases
wiring electrical connections
in fact appliances are subject to
electrical codes building codes plumbing
codes safety standards as well as
state requirements to handle gas and
electricity to ensure our products are
handled safely there is wires paramount
we have an authorized repair
professional who is trained to properly
handle our products
to ensure the customer remains safe
opening up the repair process to anyone
could have a significant impact the
safety and the reliability of the
product improper repairs could lead to
significant property damage
it could also lead to the opening up of
the connected features of the products
opening up
exposure to plus or data of the consumer
manufacturers will no longer know how
will no longer have the ability to
properly assess
whether the people entering their homes
not the necessary technical safety
insurance checks make sure the customer
remains safe
i do want to mention that any repair
provider can conduct appliance repairs
if they if the if the repair providers
seek the proper certification and
training set forth by the appliance
manufacturer
in fact there's currently a nationwide
home appliance service repair network
that includes about 20 000 service
repair shops of that 88 of those are
independent uh manufacture affiliated
so to conclude appliances are complex
products they require training and
accountability
untrained repairs can can come from our
safety and security with that i strongly
urge you to oppose house bill 449 i'm
uh okay any questions from the committee
members
uh we do have some questions
representative bartlett
thanks very much mr chairman now you can
you testify now i'll let you go oh
sorry yeah
thank you
but i'll let you go no it's all right
um you say that it's a safety issue
please tell me how
um somebody repairs a washing machine
and
um it's
not
under the purview of the manufacturer's
um representative um what the safety
issue would be
so i'll give you an example so um i i
had this issue a couple weeks ago so my
washer
had a lid switch issue what that means
is if the door is unlocked the washer
continues
so it's a big issue if you obviously
have any people who can put their hands
into it
um i called someone in and that they
fixed it
but with if you have your refrigerants
you have your
ranch hoods that require gas um so
every major appliance has
um you know gas electric wiring that
require
federal and state requirements and
certification just to handle so
ask another question
further question you may inquire thank
you um
of course these are you know these are
ordinary kinds of things that would go
with any appliance um it i can't imagine
that a repair person
um wouldn't be able to fix the
the lead uh
lock or even the refrigerant in a
refrigerator i mean you're still talking
about
being able to um
call a competent and repair man and
for the manufacturers to keep this out
why i mean
what is it that was that's a a secret
that nobody can know about to be able to
repair
uh washing machine properly
well i would say it's the the model i
mean our repaired
our authorized repairmen are trained on
the model they train on state code
they're training how to handle
every model that they've been trained
for so
there's
i mean and
and
there is independent market you can
become an authorized repairman
and not be affiliated you know with
a manufacturer you can become and you
can become trained
and the secrets if you want to you want
them you can work to get them through
the training process
may ask a question
mr chair yes can you tell us how um some
independent repairmen can become
trained yeah so it's it's two layers so
first you gotta meet all the state
requirements the federal requirements to
handle
gas electricity
uh wiring
and then um the second layer is the
manufactural
you know whole it's
obviously manufactured specific
but they'll hold you know trainings on
their models
so it's
you might have a repair
individual in new hampshire
that he he just focuses on one or two
manufacturers so those manufacturers
will hold trainings
each each manufacturer has different
training uh but
it's
and it's manufacturers they'll offer the
training
yeah and the reality is is that
in general the authorized service
technicians are people who are
affiliated with organizations that sell
that equipment so that
if you were a you know a fancy dancing
sub-zero refrigerator and in the place
where you would buy the sub-zero they
would have the
the the
train fully trained technician so
but not necessarily a third party and
that's really what this bill is about is
about third party
uh representative terry has a question
oops yes thank you mr chairman um mr
keane i'm trying to understand your uh
your uh testimony as uh completely and
as fairly as possible
is it the position of your group that
consumers
should not be in the business
quote-unquote of repairing
your own appliances
and i'd like to give you two specific
examples and
have you
have you speak to them
the upper thermostat on my electric hot
water failed just
recently i ordered the part
followed the instructions and fixed
the unit in about 15 to 20 minutes
similarly i had a problem with my
dishwasher a few years ago the printed
circuit board
that controls the dishwasher was faulty
i ordered
the part from a third party
and followed the instructions and i
completed the repair myself
do you have an opinion about that would
you prefer that i not do that
and uh called in an authorized service
dealer
or was it okay that i did what i did
some appliance repairs can be done by
you know consumers
it's it's those repairs that
involve
you know
radiation
gas electricity you know i think it's
they require certifications to handle um
so
i i've done repairs i'm not an engineer
but i've done repairs myself so
um but
in many manufactures because of you know
the high demand for repairs
they want people um they'll they'll help
you do them um doesn't have to come to
representative abramson has a question
thank you mr chair and thank you mr keen
for
sorry
for taking my question uh my my question
is
um if i own a refrigerator whether it's
10 years old or 20 years old or any
other appliance isn't it isn't it mine
to repair if i want to take it to an
independent repair shop or if i if i
know someone who does repairs
why is it uh
why should the the manufacturer have the
ability to prevent me from repairing
something that belongs to me
the manufacturer is not preventing there
there are authorized independent repair
people who can fix your refrigerator
um
it is our belief that
in order to make sure the refrigerator
lives its full life cycle it should be
fixed with it with products that would
ensure that it
lives its full life cycle we don't want
things in the refrigerator that are not
meant for that refrigerator
thank you chairman huh
thank you mr king for answering my
question mine is
in the association that you're a member
of or represent
of men original equipment manufacturers
i guess that's what they are basically
is there a commitment to
have the
parts
available for a certain period of time
so in other words if the
if the um
expected life expectancy of a
a refrigerator or something like that is
is there a commitment by the members of
your organization to
have available
uh
parts that would uh
be easily available to repair for repair
i mean there is no
formal commitment
that's between manufacturers
but
they do their best to make sure that all
the appliances on the market have the
repair parts that they can be fixed with
um so
but i mean there is no formal commitment
but they do their best to make sure that
their parts are available to fix the
refrigerator or any appliance in the
market
thank you
uh
we just had a new question
representative has a question for you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh before i ask the
question would you be willing to submit
the testimony that you read uh through
the
committee yeah yeah
yeah no problem yeah all right
there was some discussion earlier about
diagnostics
that you know you plug in a piece of
diagnostic equipment and there's an
error code that displays
and the
manufacturer
uh has control of what those error codes
mean right they're designed to have
the
they're designed to speed up the
diagnosis of the problem
but there's also
a an opportunity to kind of obfuscate
those codes um
you know not not make them publicly
available
so that only a certain number of people
know what those
special codes mean
is there any
to make those codes and those that
diagnostic equipment publicly available
so at least
some people aren't at a disadvantage in
diagnosing a problem
so
i cannot commit to that um and i think i
want to
articulate that
you know the reason diagnostic tools are
there is it make sure we have our
professionals who can handle those
diagnostics as they are
one thing to keep in mind for our
appliances is
with the smart appliances
they're all connected you know we want
to make sure people who are trained who
know where to handle those appliances
and we don't want people who can
access them freely um so i think it's
it's there's tools there that allow
people who are trained to handle those
appliances
okay follow-up question mr true what is
the question you may inquire
there's a relatively new um
thing happening
with repair and it was it was referred
to earlier in one of our first
testimonies and that is
manufacturers of not just appliances but
also cell phones and tablets and
different
types of equipment electronic equipment
the manufacturer is password protecting
the replacement of a component
and we heard that referenced uh earlier
i think it was a refrigerator so
you can die let's say you get you figure
out what the magic trouble code means
you get your hands on a
like
uh like an identical part to replace
but in order to install that part you
need a password
to install that part
what's the purpose of
password protecting
identical components
so that the manufacturer keeps control
over
uh even who can install an identical
part why would you do that
well
for personal protection um you know with
what this build does is it opens up your
home network to anyone who can come into
your house you know our industry is
unique that people can walk into your
house
and
they repair your products
having a password protection makes it so
it's just you and the people who know
the products can handle your products
so
okay
uh well thank you very much for your
testimony uh
i only have one more person and about
sometimes i'll more might pop up but
nathan proctor
who represents uh us perg and i know
what that is public interest research
group
and uh it does say you're a lobbyist are
you from uh washington or are you from
new hampshire it looks like you have a
wood stove in the back i you know i'm in
arlington i was cut you made a comment
that i was from dc and i was a little
bit insulted earlier chair hunt
um no i'm i'm here in arlington
massachusetts um it's so good to be in
france
and i was thinking oh yes no no
arlington massachusetts i said what is
he offended by you know are they just
right next to dc okay that's it for the
second yeah yes no um yeah
so anyway so happy to be here um
as chair hunts at the u.s public
interest research group we're a consumer
advocacy group with state affiliates all
over the country including new hampshire
perg and and so you know some of this
some of the things i was going to say
are covered so i'm going to just kind of
make a couple points
um you know the first is like i believe
people are capable and smart
this is my world view
i don't imagine a world in which we need
manufacturers of our appliances to
decide what we should be able to do with
them that what we can fix and what we
can't fix like people are resourceful if
you give them the parts and information
they'll probably do
more and it's their stuff so they take
responsibility
and it's and it's and i think that they
can do it i don't believe that we need
companies to dictate who who is
qualified or smart enough to do basic
maintenance of appliances
um
i i did want to say you know we've had
these products in our homes for 70 years
there's a billion or so appliances out
in america in the wild living in
people's houses if there was some safety
issue
that was a real thing
introduced by independent repair or
self-repair
there would be some data to back up that
assertion but because there isn't you
know i think that we have enough data to
say yeah that's because
you know people can manage the risk of
an appliance
you know repair without causing
themselves too many problems uh and and
then i i also wanted to talk a little
bit about
just exactly what's happening in this
industry and kind of to de-obfuscate
some of the you know certified
authorized
um questions
so
when you become authorized it's not
because you are credentialed and trained
i mean that might be part of the process
but you've signed
a contract
with the manufacturer
which gives them significant power over
what you do with their equipment um some
of these like contracts i've i've seen
they're 40 plus pages long for appliance
you know authorized technicians they
what kind of uniforms you have to wear
what kind of trucks you have to drive
and there's a lot of technicians who
do not want to sign those kinds of
contracts because they lose a lot of
independence the second thing is that
even if you're authorized for one
provider you aren't for the other one
and what manufacturers are doing in this
space
is
they use
the
access to the parts and service
documentation
uh to get people to become authorized
because without that authorization you
can't get access
and then if you're authorized you have
to do all the warranty jobs at a loss so
let's just say you're authorized by
company a you you come in to to you get
the access to the parts and information
but then you have to take the warranty
jobs and you lose money on every single
one of those warranty jobs
and you
you're limited to how many different
oems you can partner with in that
scenario because otherwise you just lose
your shirt so even if there's whatever
he said eleven thousand eighteen
thousand independent uh you know
authorized people they're only
authorized for one or two companies so
if you have a fridge made by samsung and
they're authorized ge
you know you just you don't have access
they have the same level of quality to
satisfy samsung
and they could satisfy ge but they can't
do it just because they'd lose too much
money
and so manufacturers are using this to
kind of to kind of keep their warranty
costs down but i think that has a couple
impacts on consumers one manufacturers
have a lower incentive to provide
durable products because they're
subsidizing the cost of their warranty
service
repairs
the post warranty repair costs have to
go up because the you know the
independent repair people have to kind
of make up for the losses they do on the
warranty jobs um and then it lowers the
availability of of the number of
technicians so you have
worse appliances that are harder to fix
and and more expensive and so i think i
think it's just unacceptable
we should just have access to the parts
and service information just like we did
50 years ago
this is a new change in the industry and
it doesn't make sense for consumers and
and already this is this is being done
now in france and and the eu they passed
a rule that they have to
it's even it goes farther than this bill
but this would just kind of get uh you
know the the market in new hampshire up
to speed with some with what they're
doing in some other places and with that
i'll
i'll wrap up my comments
great uh we do have a question if you're
willing to take one
representative abramson
thank you very much and uh thank you mr
proctor for your uh testimony um i did
have a question do you do you believe
it's that uh
a motivation or the motivation for
manufacturers is that they're they're
trying to uh overcharge consumers for
i you know i i don't not inside the the
heads i mean
the from talking to technicians i've
talked to i think it's this dynamic
which i just described which is they use
it to control the cost of warranty
repairs
because they can say oh you can't get
access to our you know part network or
our service documentation unless you
agree to do all the warranty jobs
you know for this price even even though
you're losing money on those um and so
if
you know if they were if they had an
open market for repair then then they
would they would have to be a little bit
more honest with their warranty charges
which i think would be good because i
think that would increase their
incentive to make products that don't
break
follow-up
for the question you may inquire
so is it the intent of this bill
that uh local shops more local shops
would be able to repair existing
appliances
absolutely yep and then i think some of
the repair shops that are authorized by
one manufacturer now can have access to
the documentation for the other
manufacturers if they get called in and
there's both an lg and a ge product that
they have to fix
all right thank you
representative
thank you and thank you for your
testimony as well
i'm going to start my question with a
statement
new hampshire
has
six tenths of one percent
of the nation's population
so if new hampshire were the only state
to have
this
bill passed is this law enacted
we would probably have a lot of
difficulty having uh the critical mass
to uh to affect anything
um can you tell us
uh
other state which states so far have
this uh have this kind of bill uh in
place
so
nationally there has been no
appliance right to repair which has been
passed or enacted
you know right now
across the country there are 19 states
considering 31
bills this is an issue which um is not
going to go away
consumers are unhappy with the status
quo whether they be
you know appliance consumers or cell
phone consumers or track you know using
tractors like this is uh it's pretty
ubiquitous in the field
uh
and it's you know it's it's gonna happen
at some point uh you know i think we
narrowed to appliances in part because i
i don't think that that the repair
control is quite as important to the
appliance industry as it is to some of
the other industries
um and i don't think that that would be
that challenging i mean i've heard on
the back end that manufacturers kind of
predict this will happen and they're
just kind of waiting it out um
yeah that's what i say
all set
okay
uh having no more questions we thank you
very much for your testimony
and
always a little daring is there anybody
in the attendees who would like to
uh see none
okay uh so we had 25 people in support
12 opposed and
i will close the public hearing on oh
representative fargo i'm sorry i'm
looking down yes
i know i just had one question i noticed
there's no fiscal note on this and yet
um
it has to be enforced by the attorney
general's office is that a concern okay
so um
i was going to discuss that when we had
the attorney general on earlier
um i've never seen a physical note come
out of the ag's office
okay so they so if if when they looked
at the bill
when a fiscal note they're sending it to
a department agency you know the terms
of who's going to write it um but ag's
office
is uh and that and
what it was uh it was a miracle to get
the secretary of state and the ag's
office to actually do rules they
wouldn't even do rules because they were
constitutionally created so they felt
that they were exempt from rumiking so
but they did do rules they have done
rules but fiscal notes i think this year
there's been an incredible darth
fiscal notes ever generated but in terms
of getting one out of that out of the
ag's office for implementation um
they're they're gonna say it's it's
undeterminable but you know i mean he
did make it clear in that one bill that
that it would be the telephone robocall
it would be a huge uh huge project that
you know how many people you have to
hire right and i just i guess that kind
of raised some concerns with me if we're
going to enforce that through through
their office and he already says his
staff is at capacity
you know how are we going to be able to
do that right right and yeah then the
idea of chasing um some samsung
to
give us the manual it might be a little
tricky
but i don't know
okay thank you sometimes it's better on
these just to have a cause of action for
someone they can take it to if
if they want to spend the money sue
don't you max you've said this a couple
of times today you just like i always
say small claims
uh
you you'd be lucky to get a
judgment against them
international corporation good luck
but they do all usa divisions i guess so
i don't know
good luck but
all right so rich i assume your hands up
just because you're still up and we're
everybody all set
so we have miraculously gone through all
our hearings
so uh which is and this is uh you know
in
well i have to say having having a zoom
meeting starting at nine we've been able
to do things a lot faster um i'm very
pleased to say that we stayed pretty
well on time i think i did good in
scheduling time you did you did
and we didn't have too much uh over and
we certainly you know had no five
o'clock session uh study you know work
section so that this works good
um and as i said earlier on just in case
some of you weren't here with that so
next tuesday um we got a day off from
commerce and then but the following week
we'll um i'll start you know scheduling
bills to to exact
do you expect it'll be both tuesday and
wednesday i'll switch i have to find out
whether they'll give me the wednesday
because i know you know this wednesday
was for us to push to the hearing so um
but we'll see how it goes and um and
i'll you know i'll be in conversation
with you chrissy once once i have an
idea where where we republicans are
going so that so that we can maybe i i i
would hope as i you know that we can go
through our exact session painlessly
without too much
you know drawn i mean i know obviously
we're not going to be on the same page
for everything but there are some things
where we can and and i and
obviously this year we're going to
retain
more bills than we've ever done before
um and i don't feel bad about that
because no just i was planning to go to
england and how they're saying we're not
going england until 2022 so so much for
that
uh don't just go earlier you know wait
till i go home i don't think i'm going
earlier
anyways okay cancel that trip to south
africa yes yeah good idea um it is the
last time i was in europe was in the off
year in september yeah
um it's my kids i got to see
it's been three years
at this point i would urge everybody to
be aware that yeah we'll we'll do these
bills
i mean we don't you know we're when we
do these subcommittees in the up we
don't we're not too busy i mean i
usually just one day a week is enough
because we actually have like six weeks
to get through things
so um and and we'll i'll have again
we'll try to break up in divisions we'll
revisit
once we know what we're retaining and
which little sub you know the
subcommittees and they can and they can
meet concurrently so so
and so i think i don't i don't expect to
take up a lot of time um and because i
do like to travel myself
in between year not election year so
we're not going to know whether you're
the season is is
flag day you know mid-june to labor
right
they roll up the sidewalks i mean you
know i mean the yacht club is closed you
know tennis they take you know it's
it's a very short season it's the same
in alton
pretty much ends
you know
um but uh so but otherwise everybody all
set we'll um we'll see see you uh who
little screens
we'll see see what happens but otherwise
uh the following week um i will be
scheduling that tuesday so okay okay all
right goodbye everybody have a good bye
bye the rest of the week and uh i guess
we're gonna have some so when's the next
zone four
uh four o'clock for the dems yes
you've got a link i sent it to you
all right